- Boys ready?
- Yeah!
- I was born ready.
- Were you though?
- No.
(laughing)
- Can we leave that in?
- Came out the womb, I'm like,
mom, I'm ready to talk
about Anime tiddies--
- [Joey] I'm fucking ready.
- Oh my God.
- Ready to get this bread, gamers.
(upbeat music)
- Welcome to this episode of Trash Taste.
I am Monkey Brain, and here
today I have two galaxy brains.
- Yes, you are correct on that.
- If anything is to go by.
- Except when it comes to chess,
which when this comes out?
- The only thing I'm
competent at apparently.
You can say it, that's it.
Everything else I'm just
rubbing sticks together, man.
- Just goldfish brain.
- Yeah man, I just can't fathom
anything else in my life.
So what can I do?
I'm useless, man.
Shout out to everyone who
defended me for my monkey brain.
Today I want to talk about, fellas,
I had a thought last night.
I was like, wow,
I've got my life together.
(laughing)
- We all know that's a lie.
No one just thinks that.
- Okay, okay.
I've got my life more
together than before.
- [Joey] Yeah, yeah.
That's better.
- And I was wondering.
I'm like, well,
I've had a drastic life
change from moving to Japan.
And that's not because of
anything to do with Japan,
that's purely because of I think the fact
that someone's holding me accountable.
Before, if I fucked up a sponsor,
it was on me.
But now there's someone else involved.
I was wondering, 'cause I'll explain mine,
but did you, you know when
you guys moved to Japan,
and you know, maybe when
you joined the agency?
Did your life change that much,
did you have a lifestyle change
or was it just the same shit?
- I think the biggest
change for me has been,
actually, this podcast.
Where we have a specific
day we come in and film,
and having something on my schedule
has just completely changed
my entire weekly schedule,
just because I have one day
that's always booked off,
and I have to plan around
that instead of being like,
I'm gonna wake up and I'm gonna feel,
like, maybe I'll feel like
working on something today,
maybe I'll just feel like
playing Ghost of Tsushima.
I don't fucking know.
- There's nothing worse I feel
than it being a Monday morning,
right?
It's a fresh start to a new week,
and you're like, alright,
let's see what I have to do this week.
And you look on your calender,
it's just nothing this week.
(laughing)
I'm just like, what do I do?
How do I do things now?
- Especially after quarantine!
You just wake up and you don't even
know what day of the week it is,
and weekends don't feel like weekends,
weekdays are just other
days, I don't know.
- Yeah, most people wake up being like,
oh, yes,
it's a Friday, it's the end of the week.
I just wake up, it's like,
it is morning.
(rooster crowing)
- A YouTuber's everyday is the same day.
- Yeah, it is.
- When everyone started working from home,
and everyone was like,
oh, yes,
this is such a refreshing
change to my lifestyle!
- And we're just like yeah.
- Yeah, welcome to the YouTuber lifestyle.
- I mean, it's fun when
everyone's doing it,
and everyone's in the same boat.
But then when everyone's doing
their normal life and working,
it's like it's hell.
- That's how I felt though,
like when we, as you said,
we started to be like, alright,
every week, this day,
this time, we're gonna
come to the studio--
- Yeah, it's really nice.
I do like that.
- And it's like (sighs quickly),
this is how normal people feel.
This is quite liberating,
I kind of like it--
- I drink coffee with other people.
- I know!
- No, it's great,
because, you know,
when I worked at the BBC,
I worked there for like two years,
like close to three years,
and I did not enjoy it after a while.
But after moving to YouTube
and being freelance,
and just going by my own schedule,
I kind of missed the office environment,
because about a year after doing YouTube,
I kind of realized, man,
if I don't actively go out
and seek social interaction,
it just doesn't happen now.
- It doesn't happen, yeah.
That took me like three or
four years to realize that.
(laughing)
I was like, do I have no friends?
Unless they, like,
drag me out?
Like, it's just weird.
- I kind of, yeah,
I kind of got that same thing,
'cause I never had a business,
like a corporate experience, right?
Like working in an office or whatever.
So it's extra exciting for me,
because I'm just,
'cause it is liberating,
'cause I've always been,
even during school,
I've always been one of
those kids where it's like,
I couldn't study on my own.
Like I had to.
- Oh, you were one of those.
- Yeah.
Like I couldn't go home and
just sit in my room by myself.
- What do you mean 'one of those'?
(laughing)
- When they'd always be like,
you all want to study together?
I'm like, no.
- Oh no, I was always like yes.
Because--
- Now I'm exactly the
same as Connor actually.
- Because I know that if I go
home and I'm in my own room
that I'm not gonna want to study.
'Cause no one's judging me
for just being like, well,
I could just play some games?
- But when I'm around my friends,
I want to talk to my friends?
- No, same here.
When there was always
a group study session,
we'd have, in university,
I remember we'd always have,
the first hour was nice and productive.
We'd start going over problems,
and then people would get bored,
and then we'd just talk about--
- You want to watch this YouTube video?
- Yeah, exactly!
(laughing)
- That's always what would happen.
- No, I was a model asian son,
so I genuinely just like, hey,
do you want to go to the library
and do some study this session?
- I don't believe you.
- And then we'd put our
headphones in and just study,
because if there's people around me--
- That's a fucking lie.
- No, no.
Legit.
- There's no way.
And we all met up, and we all studied.
- [Joey] Yeah!
- It's like?
- Why do you think I'm so galaxy brained.
(laughing)
- I'll tell you the real MVP,
which wasn't my lecturer,
but my actual real lecturer was,
shout out to those Indian YouTube lectures
that were always uploaded.
- Khan Academy re uploads?
- [Garnt] Yeah!
- Wait, what's that?
- Like if you did maths
or anything engineering,
there was always this channel.
I can't remember, it might
have been Khan Academy.
It was something like that,
where they would just upload the lectures
that are shorter and way more informative.
- Yeah, huh.
Kind of like Cliffnotes?
- Yeah, but like,
somehow they explained
it better in 10 minutes
than the two hour lecture you went too.
- You'd go to a lecture,
you'd sit there for an hour,
you wouldn't take any of this in,
and then when you're revising,
you search up, hey,
X topic, like,
how do I use, how do I do
second order integrate,
inte, I can't even fucking say--
- Integers.
And there'd just be always this,
it was always in Indian
guy doing the lectures.
I don't know why.
- They just know maths, man.
They get it, they get it.
They get it, man.
- Yeah, I never had anything like that.
I just went to the traditional route.
- If you did anything
maths or engineering,
at some point an Indian man on
the internet would save you.
Like, that's just how it is.
Like that's just,
'cause I don't know why--
- Is that maybe like only a UK thing?
- No, no,
no.
'Cause it was like Americans
too would use these things.
- I think it's an engineering thing.
Must be an engineering thing.
- Yeah, I never did engineering.
- Or the sciences.
- Maybe.
- Yeah, I never had anything like that.
I mean, I had Indian lecturers
at school who were teaching me stuff,
and they were usually the best lecturers.
- Yeah, there's so many in engineering.
- Yeah, I didn't have any,
I wish I had a YouTube channel
that I could just fucking go onto,
and being like, yes,
solve all of my problems
for me please, thank you,
so I don't have to go to classes ever.
- I felt so op when I went to university,
and it was in English,
and I was like, wait,
the internet is useful to the world.
(laughing)
'Cause like, Welsh internet
isn't really a thing.
So anytime I'd want to
cheat, I just couldn't.
'Cause I couldn't google any of this shit.
So I didn't know what I was looking up.
- [Joey] Yeah, yeah,
- But yeah, no.
Oh my God, my lifestyle in
university was so unhealthy.
Were you guys really
unhealthy at university?
- Oh definitely.
- Is there any uni student
who lives a healthy life?
- There was one guy in my year,
and he was like the
peak form of everything.
He wouldn't drink, he
went gym every single day.
He always was the best at his work--
- Sounds like he had fun.
- But what clubs was he part of?
Because I remember people who
were part of the rowing club,
or some kind of sports club,
would have always the
peak optimal lifestyle,
and then there was everyone else who was,
like, did--
- Yeah, but they would usually be the ones
where they would be
walking down the campus,
and people would know that
they're part of their club,
and everyone would just be
like, look at this wanker.
(laughing)
- Yeah, 'cause they wear their,
like, I'm in this club.
Everyone look at me, I'm in this club.
- Look at this wanker
wearing a polo shirt.
He can afford a polo shirt?
Get out of here, fuck off.
- I feel like because I went
straight into YouTube from uni.
- Yeah, you got the uni lifestyle.
- I kind of just didn't change anything,
except for, like,
I even had an approach
to YouTube making in uni.
Like I was procrastinating my videos
the way I was doing with my lectures,
where I would not do anything,
and then one day I would
just do everything.
And I would be like, wow,
what a healthy--
- I was the opposite,
because I started YouTube
when I started uni.
- [Connor] Yeah, same.
- So I kind of lived like a double life,
but usually it's supposed
to be the opposite
where it's like you should
focus on your studies,
right, and keep maintaining that,
and you know, live the
model life as a uni student,
and then YouTube just
because it's a hobby, right?
You can just procrastinate
and do whatever.
Now for me, it was the complete opposite.
I was like, alright,
upload videos every day at this time.
Get it edited, get it done.
Oh shit, I have an assignment in two days.
Oh fuck.
- Everyone who was seeing
good growth does that though,
'cause I knew that I should
have put engineering first,
but I didn't.
I put YouTube first.
- Yeah, I don't know how you managed
to do daily uploads while
also going to university,
and still pass.
I mean?
- Let's play?
- Yeah, let's play as we'll talk man.
It's some of the easiest
content that I've ever made.
And like, also,
like compared to videos now,
I wouldn't call my old
videos good editing,
because there was barely any editing.
It was lots of of cuts, lots of zoom in's.
It's like the easiest fucking editing.
Put some background music in, boom,
you've got a video, right?
Yeah, my computer,
because I really struggled
with that because obviously
the upload speed in Australia
is fucking horrendous,
like--
- As is internet.
- Yeah, the internet.
The download was fine.
We had like 20 down, which is not bad.
Not bad, right?
But do you know what our upload speed was?
- Like zero point one?
- Pretty close.
Like point three.
- Oh my God.
- Oh God.
- So uploading a 500 mg video file,
which is like nothing, right?
Would take me like eight hours.
- Jesus.
- So what I would have to do
is I would go to my classes,
I'd come back, I would work on a video,
I would edit it until the night,
and then I would upload
it and then go to sleep,
and by the time I got up in the morning,
usually it was almost
finished, or it was done.
And it would just be public by that point,
and I would do that
everyday for three years,
and unsurprisingly, it was like,
I think it was like a month
before I decided to move to Japan,
my computer just exploded.
(laughing)
Like it physically, I was sitting there.
I remember I was editing a Nekopara
episode that I was doing,
and then one day it just went, boom!
- That's Nekopara.
That's Nekopara.
- It just exploded, like
the CPU just exploded,
and the smoke coming up and everything.
I'm like, oh,
this house is gonna go down.
This house is gonna catch on fire.
- Get out, mom.
- Like, get out!
- This is how the bush fire starts.
- This is how house fires start.
Yeah, so we got rid of it,
and I opened up,
I remember I opened up the computer
and my CPU was just gone.
It was just disintegrated.
- It must have been constantly on.
You must have never turned it off--
- Constantly on, it was constantly on.
And yeah, the computer was just like,
nah, can't do it anymore man.
- Wait, did you live at home
when you were at university?
- Yeah.
- Oh shit, that must've been
such a different experience,
'cause like--
- Yeah because I never got the experience
of living in a dorm, right?
Or like, having roommates?
- I moved out at 18.
I'd just turned 18,
and I've pretty much lived alone,
or not with my parents since then.
- Yeah, I moved out after uni.
- Sounds like a fun idea
until it's really not.
After about two months of living
with other people that you realize,
man, I really hate people.
They're like--
- Well, 'cause you don't get
a say in who you're put with.
At least British university.
- [Joey] Oh, really?
- And, yeah.
Sometimes you get put with
people who you're like,
I hate this.
I was put with the rugby team, basically.
And they were destroying
everything constantly.
I remember one time I
had a pan specifically
for putting oven pizzas on, right?
- [Garnt And Joey] Right.
- And he was like, can I borrow it?
And I was like, you know,
he's 7'10, built like a brick shit house.
I was like, sure.
(laughing)
It was like a one pound tray Lidl, right?
I was like yeah, sure.
Anyway,
I go in the kitchen at night
to go and get a beverage,
and I see my pizza tray,
and there's just a carcass
of a whole chicken.
A whole chicken was
cooked on my pizza tray,
and he just left it.
I was like, there's no way
I can get this shit off.
It was charred on.
I'm like, it's not even
worth saving the tray.
I'm like, you didn't borrow it,
you just liberated it from me.
- [Joey] Just destroyed it.
- You just took it from
me and destroyed it.
I just couldn't believe it.
I was like, my mom's gonna be furious
at that one pound tray she bought me.
Furious!
How do I explain this to mother.
(laughing)
- I just, yeah.
I don't know.
I hear stories of you
people living in dorms--
- Oh dude, it was disgusting.
- It's awful.
There's always one person who was the most
disgusting person you could ever imagine.
Like you would be made
to believe by your mom
that you were a fucking slob
when you go to university.
- Oh yeah, yeah.
- And you need to wash your dishes,
you need to do this,
but then you'd meet that one guy,
and you don't know how he's
functioned his entire life.
He would just,
we had this one guy in our dorm
who would just take everything.
Take all the utilities,
and any the spare plate,
knives, and forks,
and he just would leave it in his room,
and just wouldn't wash it.
We would often get times where
we were just looking for,
like, I would be looking for my plates,
and knives, and forks,
and I had to ask him.
And one time I remember looking for,
I think it was a wine glass or something.
- [Connor] Yeah.
- And he found it in his underwear drawer.
(laughing)
And I was just like, you know what?
Just keep the damn wine glass,
I don't want it anymore.
God, how does that even end
up in that underwear drawer.
- That's disgusting.
Dude, I have so many horrible
stories from that period.
And some of the shit they
used to do to each other.
It wasn't even hazing, right?
It was just them being dicks.
I remember they didn't like this one guy
in my dorm because he was kind of pompous.
He was from South England,
and he had a very posh accent,
and he was very, very like,
oh, you're too poor to talk to me.
- Yeah, immediately sounds like a wanker.
- Yeah, he was an asshole.
Right?
And he would unironically
call people peasants.
Like I call people--
(laughing)
- Is that where you got it from?
- That's where I got it from,
because I thought it was so funny
that he called people peasants,
and he used to think that I was laughing
at the people he was laughing at,
but I used to find it so funny
that we're in the year 2000
and he's using the word
peasant as an insult.
So he would call these rugby
players, to their face,
like, peasants.
And he's not big,
but they knew they shouldn't punch him.
So what they would do, multiple times,
was piss on all of his stuff
in the middle of the night.
- [Joey] Jesus Christ.
- And leave it outside.
So they pissed in all
of his kitchen stuff,
and so he went to go
and cook the next day,
and he was like, where are my pans gone?
And I'm like, look outside.
The peasants have taken them.
I told them they shouldn't do it, but,
you know, what can I do.
- But I did not stop them.
I was like, oh no,
guys, you shouldn't be doing that--
- I was that guy in university who was,
like, not hated and not in their group,
but I was just, like,
they liked me enough where they would
tell me the shit they were doing--
- Yeah, they wouldn't fuck with you.
- Yeah, they wouldn't fuck with me.
They would always meet
in my bedroom for talks.
It was weird.
(laughing)
So they would piss on all of his stuff,
and it got completely ruined,
and they bullied the shit out of this kid.
It was awful, it was so mean.
- I mean, I don't blame them.
Like, fucking.
- [Connor] Yeah but, okay--
- If a dude came up to me
and was like, hello peasant,
I'd fucking give him a hand.
(laughing)
I'd be like, let's see how
these peasant hands feel,
motherfucker.
(laughing)
- My God, dude.
They were so crazy, man.
I can't believe the shit they'd do--
- Yeah, I hear stories like that.
I mean, I hear it from
people like you guys,
and just friends at uni who
used to live in the uni dorms,
and I'm just like, why did
you sign up for this shit?
It sounds horrible?
- It sounds like, when you're
moving into university,
it's like, oh,
it's a party everyday.
That sounds amazing.
And then you realize that people
are just dickheads most of the time.
- Yeah.
- I just had a flashback to a
horrible thing that happened.
- [Garnt And Joey] Go on, go on.
- So it was Halloween, right?
And we had a little rivalry
with the bungalow next door.
We were in bungalows by the way.
- Right.
- And, uh.
(laughing)
If you had a rivalry
with another bungalow,
and it was full of dudes,
what would you do to get back at them?
Like, what would you do?
Just send a message, right?
(laughing)
- I don't know.
- Whatever you're thinking,
it's not as disgusting as what they did.
- Just tell us what you did.
- Yeah, what did you do?
- So it was Halloween,
and I was outside having
a can of lager, right?
I was watching them do it,
and I was like, I'm not
going to be involved in this,
but I'm gonna watch this.
One of them decided it
would be a good idea
to take a shit through their mailbox.
Right?
So they did that,
and then they retaliated
by getting that shit,
putting it in a Halloween pumpkin, sorry,
and throwing the pumpkin at
one of my friends windows.
And it just exploded.
It was so disgusting.
So then they thought, okay,
this is all in the same night by the way.
This is, and again,
I'm just watching all this unfold.
I'm like, this is amazing entertainment.
(laughing)
- I can just imagine you with
your beer in hand being like,
this is better than any
anime I've ever seen.
- 'Cause they would ask you, like,
you reckon I should do this?
I'm like, that's a great idea.
Looks great.
- [Joey] Go for it, yeah.
- Fantastic idea.
Then they're like, watch this.
And then one of the rugby guys was like,
I'm gonna smash their door in as a joke.
I'm like, that's an amazing joke.
That's so funny.
And so they smashed his door down,
front door to their bungalow.
They smashed it down as a
joke, just destroying their?
- Just destroy property.
- Yeah, wasn't even theirs.
And then the university
obviously found out the next day,
and was like, who did this?
And I was like, I have no idea.
(laughing)
And they got in so much shit for it.
- Does it have to do with
the poop on the window?
- Like, why is there a
pumpkin and shit involved?
(laughing)
- They're like literally monkeys,
just showing shit all over the place.
- Just flinging shit at each other.
- Basically, these guys
were all in the rugby squad,
in the biggest rivalry in Wales,
and rugby is the big.
Imagine, like,
I don't know which state is the biggest
American football state,
but imagine the biggest meatheads
in America just in the same place.
- I mean, we kind of have that
in Sydney as well with rugby.
- Disgusting shit is gonna happen,
and I guess because I was just, like,
they liked me enough,
it wasn't hell for me.
I mean, they would still
use my shit all the time,
and it was really annoying--
- Were you in the really cheap dorms?
- Oh, I was in the ones
that cost 70 bucks a month.
- Okay, okay.
- Jesus Christ.
- I had what would have been
a psychiatric prisoner room,
like, it's the bare.
They gave us a mattress
and I wish they didn't,
because I immediately, when I got there,
I pick up my mattress
and it's bright yellow,
the bottom of it.
And I'm like, oh God.
(laughing)
And I remember getting
homesick the first day.
I'm like, mom,
I can't do this.
This is disgusting, like.
It was literally a tiny
room with a shit stained bed
that they'd obviously never changed.
- It was obviously, like,
university dorms are basically
just remodeled prison cells.
- Yeah.
- Like I think I'd rather go to jail.
- Plus shitty internet connections.
(laughing)
- I think I'd rather go
to jail at that point.
- Because the bed that they gave us,
I remember thinking, oh,
it's probably gonna be a single bed.
I didn't know there was a size
smaller than a single bed.
(laughing)
- Wait, there is?
I didn't know that!
- I swear, because it was way
smaller than a single bed.
You'd sleep like this.
Anything else and my feet,
because I'm like a fairly tall guy,
I'm not even that tall.
I'm six foot.
My feet would always be off the bed.
That's how small my bed was.
- Just like three pillows
stitched together.
Sorry, there's your mattress.
Jesus Christ.
Yeah, I'm glad I never experienced that.
I would just bite the bullet,
and just take the two hour travel
between my uni and my house,
and I'd just be like, I'm in
the comfort of my own home.
- I learned some important life
lessons at university though.
I learned, like,
sometimes you just gotta say fuck
everyone else and put yourself first.
(laughing)
- I learned that afterwards.
- Uni people would just fucking take
advantage of you if you're like--
- Oh, definitely.
- Yeah.
- Because there was only one bus
that made it to the campus on time.
Like, it was an half an hour bus.
It's only one bus.
And this line would be fucking
huge to get on this bus,
so if you were late, it was just whatever.
And I got to the point
where I was just like,
I'm going to be so late for my
lecture if I wait in this line.
I would literally just, like,
when people were getting on the bus,
I would just walk to the
front of the line and get on.
- [Joey] Push in.
- I would literally just
act as if I was on the bus.
I would just walk up.
Yeah, bus.
And then everyone would
look at me like, the fuck?
You can do that?
And I was like, fuck it.
I don't care.
- That's like, sacrilegious in England.
- British, yeah.
That is like a cardinal.
And I would never do that,
but I thought because they're all
a bunch of university students,
I'm like, fuck you.
It's survival of the fittest, bitches.
- We used to do that in high school.
Do you guys have middle school
and high school separated?
- No, no.
We don't.
- It's all seventh graders
to 12th graders altogether,
right?
- Okay, so it's the same in Australia.
And, you know,
every time the school finishes,
there'd always be lines for different
bus routes that would go.
- [Connor] Yeah, same--
- And of course all the fucking
seventh graders and eighth
graders are just like,
I'm gonna get on,
they just start fucking running up.
And the 12th graders and the
11th graders would just be like,
out of the way, bitch.
(laughing)
They'd fucking push these
kids out of the way.
And they couldn't do anything,
but it was the most
liberating thing to do.
Finally, when I got to the 11th grade,
I was like, I understand.
I have power now.
It's fucking awesome.
- Learn the hierarchy, bitch.
- Yeah, exactly.
Step down.
- Dude, do you have any horror university
stories then that weren't dorms?
Anything at all that was
fucked up, or anything funny?
- I mean other than the friend I had,
like, other than one of my
friends being a drug dealer,
like not really?
I mean, I don't really have
to go into detail on that obviously.
- Yeah, it's up to you.
- You just see so much shit in university.
Like, you know,
your story about throwing
the poop at the bungalow?
- Yeah, I don't have anything that crazy.
- You don't--
- No,
that was really common for us.
You'd see--
- That was really common did you say?
- Yeah.
(laughing)
- What fucking universities did you go to?
- Just walking around
campus and I'm just like,
I didn't know I could ever see
shit in a location like this?
- Yeah, you see vomit
and shit where they're,
like, you're fascinated how it got there.
- I understand the vomit, right?
Because we had a whole bunch of pubs
and restaurants within the campus,
where it's obviously you
get a little bit crazy,
as you do as uni student,
and you throw up a little bit.
But I'm just like, why is there,
like, poop on this sidewalk?
And it's like--
- Actually, now that you
guys are mentioning it,
I'm remembering so much poop that
I have just blocked out of my memory.
- I'm like, this is bigger than an animal.
It's not an animal, it's
clearly not an animal.
Like, this is a human poop.
I know a human poop when I see it.
- No, they are an animal.
(laughing)
- It's not even like a
kangaroo or a big animal,
this clearly came out of a human.
- I think it must have been
pretty bad at my university,
because they had a row of
port-a-potties that would just
pop up on Friday though Sunday
at where all the clubs were.
So clearly people must
have been shitting enough
and pissing that they were like,
we gotta sort this out.
They're pooping everywhere!
- I just keep remembering there's
so much poop where there shouldn't be.
Like, I remember.
- This is probably out
most amazing podcast--
(laughing)
- There's this one time when
I came home from a night out,
and I was in the common room,
and it just smelt like
someone had died there.
It smelt like an animal had died.
Maybe it was a dog or something?
Started looking around,
searching for where this
smell is coming from.
I'm playing a game of Where's Wally.
Just with the smell, right?
I'm searching everything.
- What the fuck.
- It was around Christmas time,
and so I searched behind,
there was, I searched
behind the Christmas tree,
'cause it was coming
from the Christmas tree.
So I look behind,
and there's just this turd sitting
where there should be presents.
And my first thought is surely
this can't be a turd, right?
And, like you said,
it's not like a dog turd.
It's like a full on.
- It's clearly a human turd, right.
- Yeah, it's not like
rabbit poop or something.
It's like a big, full on turd.
My first thought is surely
there's no way this is a turd?
- This is in your house?
- Huh?
- In your house.
- Yeah, in my dorms.
In my dorms.
So it wasn't a house,
we lived in a shared
dormitory of 200 people,
so we had a common area.
So I get this fucking stick, right,
and I start poking it,
just thinking maybe it's something
else other than the turd.
Maybe it's like a toy, a fake turd--
- A big chocolate bar!
- And the stick just sinks in.
I'm like, oh.
Oh, this is a fucking turd.
Oh, I am smelling shit right now.
How did this get here?
'Cause it was in the common room!
'Cause it was pretty late
but people come here,
people come in the
common room pretty often,
and I was just like, I was just thinking,
there must be a story behind this.
How did this turd appear here?
(laughing)
- Did you find out?
- I never found out.
- Oh my God, that's such
a wasted opportunity--
- All I remember was
coming in the next day,
in the morning, and it
was just magically gone.
And I'm just like,
I feel sorry for the person who had
to clean that turd up, man.
- See, I just hear shit like that,
I'm just like?
- Yeah, but don't you,
like, you get some fucking stories
that you're never gonna forget.
- Oh yeah, of course.
But I like hearing it from other people.
I don't wanna go through
the fucking trauma
of experiencing a lovely
Christmas morning with a turd.
Right, like?
I don't need that in my life.
- He wasn't affected.
He's like, I'm gonna go back to my room.
Fuck this.
- I'm just like,
I'm out, man.
- That's a fun story.
(laughing)
This is why, okay,
this is why people on
the comments were like,
why does Connor have so many stories?
'Cause I just say yes to the dumbest shit,
thinking like, okay,
if this goes horribly wrong,
at least I get a banger of a
story out of this, probably.
Like yes,
I'll do that thing that's
probably very questionable.
Like, sure.
Let's go there, let's do this thing,
because I'm gonna get a
banger of a story out of this.
I love that.
- I just forget a lot of stuff sometimes.
I got through my life--
- Yeah, I get flashbacks.
Sometimes we're talking?
I'm like, oh shit.
- Speaking of poop, I remember that story.
- No, 'cause going back to
lifestyle in university,
I remember I had the most unhealthy
lifestyle you could possibly imagine.
- [Connor] Oh yeah, 100%.
- A human body shouldn't be able
to do that many all-nighters,
and somehow I had a diet that just
consisted of mostly Red Bull.
- How many Red Bull's
would you drink a day?
And coffee?
- I would drink at least
three cans of Red Bull a day,
and like two cups of coffee.
- Yeah, same.
- That sounds about right.
- But on some all nighters
when I had an assignment,
that was never ever done until the night
before I had to put in my assignment,
'cause who the fuck actually
does assignments weeks before?
I remember one night I had,
I think it was 10 cans of Red Bull.
- Your heart rate must have been insane.
- Oh no, it was insane.
- Don't do this, by the way.
- Do not do this!
This is a cautionary tale.
And the deadline was at 8AM,
and I finished it at 7AM,
and I remember thinking, yes,
I can finally submit it.
So I submitted it and
I lay down in my bed,
and I could not stop shaking.
I was just like.
(laughing)
And I remember that was the exact
moment that I remember thinking,
man, I need to sort my fucking life out.
(laughing)
- Just like, I'm gonna die.
- Yeah.
- Dude, because I ate like shit,
and I was drinking like 10,
not 10 Red Bull's,
like at least three
Monster Energy's a day,
on top of coffee,
and then also eating Domino's
Pizza two times a week.
- Oh yeah, I kinda had a similar story,
where like, a lot of the times,
because I wasn't living
in the dorms, right?
I would just sleep over in the
room that I was working on,
right?
I remember I had a programming
assignment I had to do,
and it was, of course,
it was a teamwork job,
and that never goes well in uni.
There's always that one fucker
who never appears to any
of the fucking assignments.
And I was just like,
and it was just me and a friend,
and we were just waiting
for this third person.
We're like, where the fuck is he?
He's like the best at programming here.
We can't do it just with the two of us.
Of course, the dude never showed up,
so it was just like, great.
Well, the thing's due in like,
what, three hours?
It's like five in the morning right now.
Let's just order Domino's.
So we just fucking called up the Domino's.
We order fucking seven
pizzas or something.
We're just like, hey everybody,
if you're at the uni right now,
just come to this room.
Ordered like seven Domino's.
Just come in here and we'll eat Domino's.
And the next morning I
remember the professor came in,
and it was just like seven
empty boxes of pizza's,
and just eight of us all
sprawled out on the ground,
just with pizza hangovers.
And, yeah.
That was the best story I have.
Obviously not as
interesting as a poop story,
but, uh.
- Where's the poop?
- I'm not invested in this story.
- Did someone shit themselves at least?
(laughing)
- I mean, we definitely all
smelt like shit the next day.
But that's about it, yeah.
- I'm sure I have way more
stories that I can think of,
but none of them are
coming to me right away.
- [Garnt And Joey] Yeah.
- I just forget a lot of them.
- Dude, I didn't realize that,
like, I got super chubby
during university.
I know Garnt is like, Connor,
you never looked chubby.
But dude.
- Connor swears to me that he was
chubby when I first met him,
and I just have completely
blanked out this memory of him.
- Mood man, put this image on screen.
This was, like,
two years ago or whatever?
- To be fair though,
I look back at old photos I have of you,
and I'm like, man,
this boys face is round.
- Right?
And I never thought I was chubby, right?
- I didn't think you
were at the time, yeah.
- I think because it was
just the way I'm built?
Like I don't look that chubby.
- Right, right.
- But I remember a year ago,
like, I saw an image.
Someone had taken a photo of
me and it was from the side,
and I just saw my stomach
hanging over a little bit,
and I'm like, what the fuck?
When did that happen?
And you're like, what?
And then you start realizing,
oh shit, I'm chubby.
Like, I'm actually chubby.
- That's so weird,
because I had such shit diet
and lifestyle choices in uni,
but I was so fucking.
Like when you first met me,
I was fucking emaciated.
- Yeah, you were so skinny--
- Everybody always says that
I was so fucking skinny.
- You were so skinny!
- To put it in comparison, right,
all throughout high school,
I haven't really grown in
height since high school.
I'm hovering around 180 centimeters.
A little under six foot.
In high school, I think I
never broke 60 kilograms.
- Jesus Christ.
- What are you now then?
- I am 75 now.
- Oh shit--
- Yeah, I gained a lot.
- Chunked up.
(laughing)
- You look healthy though!
- Yeah, you look healthy.
- It's 'cause I went to America.
(laughing)
And I was just going ham,
and I didn't realize that, oh,
metabolism is a thing.
- Yeah, I realized that during university.
Obviously I'd been going,
taking advantage of my body way too much.
- [Joey] Oh yeah, yeah.
- And then pretty much last
year I just went ham on myself,
and cut out everything.
Cut out energy drinks,
went gym five days a week
and lost 10 kilograms.
- Yeah, 'cause I remember back then,
I didn't know if I had a bigger
tolerance in alcohol or caffeine,
but it was always,
I was drinking equally much of both,
and equally destroying my body with
as much shit as I was eating as well.
- Yeah, I was probably
eating in food alone,
like, 3000 calories?
Probably consuming 2000
calories at least in alcohol.
And that's not even the Monster Energy
drinks that were probably
like 1000 calories,
plus all that.
So I was going ham on my body,
because, you know,
when you're 19, you're like,
bro, I don't gain weight.
I've never been fat, I'm
never gonna gain weight.
- I mean, that's the thing,
and I had an insane diet when I was
in high school and uni as well,
and it's not just the shit I was eating,
but just how much of it I was eating.
Like, lunch,
high school lunches for
a lot of people is like,
you know, maybe a sandwich,
or you know, or a hot dog maybe.
Something like that.
I used to have 10 slices of bread.
- I could do that, I used to do that.
- And just devour that
before the noon hit.
I was just like, I just got to school,
I'm feeling a little bit hungry.
I'll just eat, like,
three sandwiches.
And I was still skinny as shit,
and people were like, how?
- [Connor] I'm jealous.
- How violent are your shits?
(laughing)
Because that's the only way
you're getting rid of it!
- I think it's that asian blood, man,
because I've consistently, like,
I've been about the same
weight my entire adult life.
- I'm jealous, I'm so jealous.
- I don't know.
I think my body just, when I eat,
when I start gaining weight,
my body just shuts off and it's just like,
I don't want any food.
Like, I'm just never hungry.
So it's, I don't know.
It's never been a big deal for me--
- That's a fucking super power, bro.
(laughing)
- I mean, I'm okay with it now,
because I went from dangerously
skinny to just normal weight,
but obviously people who have
stuck around on my channel,
and have seen me in that
emaciated state are just like,
Joey's gotten really fat.
I'm like, no,
I just went back to normal.
That's all that happened, I'm not fat.
- We all know YouTube
comments like to nit pick, so.
- Yeah, exactly.
- With university life,
did you guys feel the same where,
you know, my parents always told me,
you know, when you go to university,
that's when you grow up.
That's, you know.
(laughing)
- Is that what they said?
- Yeah, yeah,
yeah!
'Cause that's where you're
treated as an adult, right?
With responsibility and stuff.
But anyone who's still in university,
it's such a warped experience
of what adult life is like.
- Yeah
- You know what I mean?
- Yeah.
'Cause I guess university is kind of
like the ramp to being an adult,
the way I saw it?
There was people there who
left university who I'm like,
you should not be living alone.
You cannot take care of yourself.
And then there was other
people who I'm like,
yeah, you know,
they'd be fine.
You know?
Like, I guess--
- I feel like if you can't
take care of yourself at uni,
you're really gonna have a hard time
taking care of yourself after uni as well.
- Oh, we've definitely met those people.
(laughing)
- Half the people I lived
with were incapable.
One of them was, like,
a serial gambler and lost all his money.
(laughing)
- One of my friends was the same.
One time, he won 10K.
10K, for a uni student,
in a casino, which is insane.
- He's basically a
millionaire at that point.
- Yeah, yeah.
You're basically a fucking millionaire.
And everyone was like, no fucking way,
you won that much?
He lost it within two weeks.
(laughing)
Two weeks!
Because he was so addicted to gambling.
It's fucking insane.
- Oh God.
- I asked him, how could
you spend that much?
You could have paid off your
student loans and everything.
And I remember him just saying, oh,
'cause it just didn't mean anything to me.
- That was like a guy
in the house next to me,
the one that got pooped in,
as you gentlemen know.
(laughs quickly)
- Yeah, as we all know.
- And he was basically like a neo-Nazi,
and he was really fucking weird.
And he would always come over and bring,
like, two forty year old women,
and he was having
threesome's with them both.
And he would exclusively
refer to them as sugar tits.
(laughing)
- Did he time travel from the 50's?
- And he was like, and
I remember one time,
'cause my friends--
- Come here, sugar tits.
- Yeah, he was like,
yeah, he was literally like that.
My friend was telling me, he was like,
yeah, it's really weird.
He was mixing chemicals in his room.
And I was like, bro.
Tell the fucking university people.
Like, what do you mean he's
mixing chemicals in his room?
- You're really doing a good
job selling on Wales as being,
like, this--
(laughing)
- Where'd you go again?
- I don't want to name the university
in case they get really mad at me,
but--
- Bristol university represents.
- Sydney Uni.
- You can find out what
university I went too.
(laughing)
- It's not that hard,
it's somewhere out there.
- And, like,
he was always that guy who was like,
you know when someone
would talk about a fight,
they were like, well,
if I had my Glock then it would be over.
You know what I mean?
And you're like, what?
What do you mean?
- Come again?
(laughing)
- It's just those guys who are like,
yeah, I know how to use a gun.
(laughing)
It's like, yeah,
a gun would fix that, always.
He talks about guns too much.
He brought up Mein Kampf an
uncomfortable amount of times.
- Right.
- I remember.
- My favorite piece of literature.
(laughing)
- I remember one time he was like,
his excuse for not doing an
assignment was 'cause he was
too in-depth into reading
about Nazi history,
and how interesting it was.
And that's always a double edged
sword when they're telling you that--
- It's like a red flag.
- Yeah.
- It's like, are you interested in it,
or like, interested in it?
Like, are you?
- This sounds like an episode
of Peep Show or something.
- It is, yeah.
It is, it was!
I luckily never had to deal
with him, but my friend did.
Apparently one time he,
my friend, who was telling me all this,
had borrowed something from
the neo-Nazi character,
and it was in his room,
and his room was locked.
And so this guy didn't want
to wait 30 minutes to do it,
so he just took all the bolts off
his door with a screwdriver set,
and just removed the door and went in,
and never gave him his door back,
like the stuff?
(laughing)
For like two weeks before the
university came and fixed it,
the dude had no door,
and he had a gaming PC and everything.
Like, the dude just had no door,
and the front door to this
bungalow was always left open.
- There's taking, you know,
like utensils?
And then there's taking a door.
(laughing)
- He took the door, like all the,
what the fuck, the door handle,
all the hinges,
he just took it off and just
removed the door to the side.
It's like a caveman with a stone entrance,
like, oonga boonga,
I need my keys, or something.
Whatever it was.
This dude was insane.
He was the kind of guy who, like,
when you were around him for five minutes,
you were like, I don't want
to be around you anymore.
You've said too many uncomfortable
things in five minutes.
And when he brought his two 40
year old women girlfriends around.
Like, they're disgusting.
Get them out of my house.
- His sugar tits.
- Yeah, it's so gross.
I was like, 20,
clearing my dishes, like
what the fuck is happening?
- So how did you transition from
university life to your working,
YouTube schedule, adult life?
The real adult life, or
whatever we want to call it.
- So, I think for me,
I'd finished university.
I broke it to my parents that
I didn't want to do a Masters.
They were like, fair enough.
You clearly didn't want to do a Bachelors.
(laughing)
Which I did.
I passed it with a good
grade, so it's fine.
And I was like, you know what?
I go to London a lot.
Why not fucking move to London on a whim?
I moved to Japan on a whim,
moved to London on a whim.
Went there and just, that
was kind of it really.
- Because when you met
Sydney for the first time,
had you already decided that
you were going to London?
- Yeah, yeah I knew pretty much,
like, I wanted.
About half way through my last
year of university I was like,
I don't like Wales anymore.
I really, really like London,
so I'm gonna move to London,
and even though the prices were insane,
I managed to find a roommate
to help me split the costs,
and, yeah,
just kind of went into it.
And it was really weird,
'cause it was like,
I don't know, just doing the same shit,
just in a different city, I guess?
- Yeah, but no one teaches
you about that shit.
You just gotta do it and
just hope for the best.
- You're like, oh shit,
I have to pay taxes?
How do I figure that out?
And it's like, oh shit,
okay, I need to figure this out--
- I have to check the mailbox?
Ew.
- Just so many things
you have to figure out
and hope that you're doing right.
- [Garnt] Yeah, yeah.
- I don't know, what was it for you?
'Cause obviously you
did a way bigger leap?
- Yeah, because I mean,
I had a gap year.
- Gap year.
- A gap year between from,
in between actually starting,
between graduating from uni and actually
starting my job at the BBC,
and that was when I kind of went, like,
that was when I went all out on YouTube
before I just completely stopped.
So the period before I completely stopped,
I spent a lot of time on YouTube
because I had basically
nothing else to do.
- Were you still not making any
money during that time as well?
- Yeah, I wasn't making any money--
- Oh wow.
- Oh shit.
- It was just because I
had nothing else do to,
and I was really enjoying it,
and, yeah,
because that was about
the time Podtaku started,
and a lot of new things were happening--
- Right, so you were pretty
heavily invested at that time?
- Yeah, I was pretty
heavily invested in that.
And I remember, this was
such a weird year for me,
'cause I would spend my
time all over the world,
just in different places.
Like, I lived in China for a bit.
- Really?
- Yeah!
- Why?
- Um, for reasons I don't
really wanna get into.
- Okay, yeah--
- But I was there for a bit,
and then I was in Thailand for a bit,
and most of the time I was
just working on YouTube videos,
and by the end, I wanted something stable.
I wanted a job.
I thought I wanted a
job at the BBC, right?
(laughing)
- I thought wrong.
- And it was good for the first year.
About the first year.
It was a good experience.
It was like, yes,
this is a nice break from university,
and just doing YouTube for a while,
'cause what I didn't realize is how hard
university life is compared
to having a real job.
- Yeah.
- Like you guys don't know,
but the shit,
the stress and shit you go through in uni
is like 10 times as much as anything
you'll go through in a normal job--
- You've got drama on top of having to do
10 assignments all at one time,
and your exams, like.
- 'Cause it's like, if
I fail one assignment,
I am stuck here for the rest of my life.
- Yeah, like I've been stressed,
but never as stressed as I
was at university sometimes.
'Cause they always,
I don't know if it was
the same for you guys,
but in my university they always put all
the deadlines at the same fucking time--
- Same time, yeah.
- So it was always two months of, like,
I'm having a great time,
playing League of Legends 12 hours a day,
got nothing to do,
and then, boom,
November hits.
You have eight fucking assignments,
two exams coming up,
and four exams on top of
that two exams that you have,
and you're like, holy shit,
holy fuck--
- Just constantly shitting in your pants.
Just like, I'm gonna die.
I'm never gonna get out, yeah.
- But I still had my really unhealthy
lifestyle I had in university
in my job at the BBC.
Okay, so let me explain to you
my sleep schedule for the BBC.
- Oh, I want to get it.
This is one I really wanted to talk about.
- Okay, yeah,
because my sleep schedule was disgusting.
- [Connor] Hell yeah.
- Because, at the time,
a lot of my friends were online,
and a lot of them, unfortunately,
were in north America,
which the best time to
talk to them was either,
like, probably really late for us.
You know?
So you just get used to
staying up super, super late.
So that was fine when I was in university,
'cause it was easy to
do all nighters anyway,
but when I was working at the BBC,
I had a nine to five job.
So I'd need to get up.
I lived five minutes
away from my workplace,
that was a good thing,
because if I didn't,
my sleep schedule would be
even worse than it already was.
So I would stay up until
about 4AM everyday, right?
- Seems pretty normal.
- Yeah, but I would wake up at eight.
So I would have four hours of sleep,
do my nine to five--
- It's all that monk preparation.
- Yeah.
- Do my nine to five
with four hours of sleep,
be fucking dead for the entire day,
and then go back home,
and around five, six o clock--
- [Connor] Do the same shit.
- Have a two hour nap and then
that was my sleep schedule.
I never had one long sleep,
it was always intermittent.
Like I would have a maximum of,
like, three to four hours at a time,
every night, just spaced out by,
like, eight hours.
That was my sleep schedule for four years.
- Jesus.
- I think being friends with Americans,
especially in the UK,
because of how the time zone's work,
you're like five hours ahead.
You end up, like you're talking to them,
you're having a good time,
and you're like, yeah,
I can talk for an hour extra.
And then it'd constantly,
like, the hour extra adds.
- Yeah, exactly.
- And before you know it the sun's rising,
and you're like, fuck.
- Yeah.
- Did you have a bad sleep schedule?
- Oh yeah, of course.
- Oh, okay.
- I was the similar thing because,
as you said, like,
a lot of my YouTuber friends
were in North America,
or not in Australia essentially,
so I always had to adjust
to their time zones,
and that was usually like three or 4AM.
But at least I didn't
have to get up at 8AM.
I would get up at maybe like 2PM.
- Yeah, that was like--
- If I got up before noon,
that was weird for me.
I'm just like, this isn't right?
I can feel the morning sun!
(laughing)
I felt the morning sun
before I went to bed.
- I don't know if you guys did this,
but I would, like,
just slowly deteriorate my
sleep schedule till it got
to the point where I
was going to bed at six,
7AM, and then I would,
you know, wake up at 4PM.
Whatever, right?
I would do the thing where
I would completely fuck it,
and then I'm like, I'm gonna fix it today.
And then I fix it,
and I immediately start
just chipping away at it.
(laughing)
- It offsets by an hour,
and then an hour turns into two hours.
- [All] Yeah.
- And then two hours
turns into three hours.
- 'Cause you'll have that one night,
and I'm sure you've had it,
where you're just like,
for some reason you stayed up until 8AM.
- [Garnt And Joey] Yeah.
- And you're like, fuck.
There's not coming back from this--
- And for some reason when
you stay up until 8AM,
It's easier to keep on that sleep schedule
than keep on a healthy schedule, right?
- Yeah, it's so,
like, I physically,
like, I remember last year,
it was so hard for me to try and fix this.
I would try and stay up, I would fail,
and then I would try to wake up early,
and I would fail.
So I was just in this loop for like,
I remember two months of just
tryna fucking fix this thing,
and I could not do it.
And then when I did, I
had to fly to America.
And then come back, and
it's immediately fucked.
So it's like I couldn't win.
I know this sounds so stupid.
It's like, just wake up early,
Connor.
Like, lol,
he XD,
just wake up early, just do it.
But it's like for some reason
when you're a YouTuber,
and you have no responsibilities,
it's impossible to fix this shit--
- Just put an alarm on your phone.
(laughs mockingly)
- It takes so much willpower
to fix your sleep schedule.
- Oh yeah, yeah.
- It's really difficult
when you don't have
any responsibilities or
a schedule to stick by,
or people relying on you,
apart from your viewers.
- This year's probably the
first year that I think
almost everyday I've gotten
up at a normal human time.
- Yeah, 'cause I remember
when I first moved here,
you were still waking up pretty late.
- Oh yeah.
When I was first living here,
at my previous place before
Aki moved in with me,
I was getting up at, yeah,
maybe 12, 1PM?
And I'm just like, yeah,
this is a reasonable time.
I went bed at like 5AM last
night, so I got my sleep.
- I think being on this time zone,
like, American's are always
asleep when I wanna do shit,
so I just go to bed and
then they're all awake.
So it's like I don't feel
any pressure to stay up here.
There's no reason, unless I'm out.
You know?
- Because I remember you talked before
about how you would record videos at 2AM?
- Yeah, I'd record,
'cause I woke up at six?
I don't wanna do anything when I wake up.
6PM, by the way.
I'd wake up at 6PM,
in Wales, right before I moved to Japan.
Because I was kind of like, I don't know,
I was pretty depressed.
I was like, I hated it.
I was just like, I just
wanted to move to Japan.
I was just stuck in this shitty
bedroom that I didn't like.
It was my brother's bedroom,
it wasn't even mine,
I hated it.
- It wasn't the attic room?
- No, no.
No, I fucking,
I wish it was.
At least there'd be more space.
I hated this room, I hated being in Wales.
I'm sorry, parents.
I love you, but I hate Wales.
They know I hate living in Wales.
I hated it so much.
I had no friends really,
and so I would just stay up until, like,
nine, 10AM?
- [Garnt] Yeah?
- And then I would go
to bed, wake up at 6PM.
And then I couldn't do anything as well,
'cause everything was closed.
- Right.
- So I was just a perpetual cycle.
- Everything opens and then
closes while you're asleep.
- Literally,
literally everything would
open and close while I sleep,
and then I wanted to eat anything,
like, I couldn't.
I had to preemptively go to the shop
to buy things that I
think I would want later,
to eat for dinner.
- I think, like,
I had a similar problem
like that in Japan,
but I think it's because
I was relying too much
on the convenience of the
24 hour convenience store.
- Yeah, the convenience.
- Yeah, because I would get up at,
you know, I'd stay up
until maybe like 3AM?
And I'd be like, oh,
I'm a bit hungry.
Everywhere else in the world,
you're pretty much fucked.
You have to look in your fridge.
- Not America.
- I mean, you can do delivery,
and stuff like that,
but it's no, you know.
In my case, I would get out of the house,
literally walk 20 meters to the 7-Eleven
that was across the road from my house,
and just grab something, and come back.
And I'm like, yeah,
of course I'm gonna stay up,
because there's no time
limit with food especially,
or anything like that, right?
- [Connor And Joey] Yeah.
- But, yeah.
Recording at 2AM though?
That's insane.
- Like, 4AM.
- Yeah, 2AM,
4AM.
How do your neighbors find it?
- Fuck 'em, dude.
(laughing)
Dude, I would be in bed at like,
what was it?
This is when my sleep
schedule wasn't too bad,
like 4AM,
and I would hear fucking Peppa Pig
fucking blasting through my wall.
It's (muffled singing).
Like, muffled?
And I'm like, shut the fuck up.
It's 4AM.
So I didn't give a fuck.
I was like, fuck it.
They were assholes to me, so I was like,
you know what I'm gonna do?
- You should have just blasted
Peppa Pig back at them.
- DMX through the wall.
Like, Peppa Pig version?
(laughing)
- I have a similar experience to
the first house I lived in in London,
'cause if you live in London,
you're gonna live in a shared house.
That's just the way it is in London.
So we had paper thin walls, right?
And I lived next to this couple who just,
like, would not stop having sex.
(laughing)
- Good on them, good on them--
- No, no.
Good on them.
But it wasn't like the discreet sex.
Like, they were loud,
and it wasn't even sexy loud.
The girl just sounded like a dying dog.
That's kind of like the kind
of noise I had to live with.
But I think they did that
because they got annoyed
at me recording podcasts and videos.
- They're like, I'll show him!
- They would choose to have sex
right whenever I start recording.
It was, coincidentally,
every time I'd start recording a video
I'd just hear these
fucking moans on the wall,
and I would have to wait a good,
sometimes it was an hour.
I don't know what couple constantly
has sex for an hour every time.
I swear they were taking the piss.
- Were they filming a porno?
(laughing)
- How slowly was the
guy going, fucking hell?
- I think they were just having
shouting contests because they were just
annoyed at me recording
videos and podcasts.
So some episodes of Podtaku
you can kind of hear.
We had to blank out my
audio because there's
just moans in the background.
(laughing)
- Release the uncensored footage.
- They were like,
the moment they just look,
they're just putting
their ear to the wall,
and the moment they hear 'warning',
they're just like, alright,
let's go.
Let's go, right now.
Come on, put your pants out.
Put your pants down, let's go.
(laughing)
- Honey, start moaning.
Honey, honey?
(laughing)
It wasn't even the videos
that I was loudest for,
It's like,
sometimes I would record voiceover
that was full on battle cries,
and it would literally be like,
and I can shout loud!
It would be like full on battle
cries in my fucking house,
at like 1AM,
'cause it was the only time
that I was awake and ready.
- Anywhere else in the world,
they'd think a murder was happening--
- Yeah, they would!
Dude, they didn't give a fuck in London.
They were like, I don't know,
we live in South London.
It's South London, what can you do?
(laughing)
God, dude.
Yeah, I did not like my neighbors.
They were assholes.
And the one time they
stole my package as well,
so fuck 'em.
Fuck you for stealing my package.
- Yeah, I see it.
The only experience
I've ever had of living
or having neighbors to worry
about is here in Japan,
but it's never been anything like that.
I mean, I had that really one,
recently, that one really
passive aggressive woman--
- Yeah, below you,
right?
She gave you a note?
- She gave me like a,
it's not the one time either,
that's like the third or
fourth letter she sent me.
- Can you explain the whole story?
I'm interested, 'cause I
don't know the timeline.
- So basically,
I don't even remember
when the first one was.
But basically I came home once,
and in Japan,
I don't know if it's in
other countries as well,
but at least in Japan, in apartments,
they have a mailbox
downstairs on the first floor,
and they also have a little
mail entry thing on the door?
- I think that's a normal thing.
- I think, I don't know.
But basically I came home and
I was about to open the door,
and I saw a piece of paper sticking out,
so I'm like, okay,
must be a flyer or something.
- Missed a package.
- Yeah, missed a package or something.
And I open it, and it's this really,
it was really creepy,
because it's like to nobody,
it was clearly typed out,
and it was just in English.
And I read it and I'm like,
this sounds Google translated.
And I read it, and it's the woman,
it's a guy or a woman downstairs.
I don't even know who it is,
because when you first move
to an apartment in Japan,
it's customary to go to
every room that's adjacent.
- Yep.
- I'll tell my story about that after--
- So the two rooms to the
left and right of you,
and the person below and
above you, if there are any,
and go and basically say, like,
hey, I just moved in here.
You know, if you ever need anything,
I'm in this room kind of thing.
The two people to the sides of me?
Fucking great, I love both my neighbors.
The woman at the top?
Super nice.
Barely talk to her.
But the woman at the bottom?
She didn't even come to the door.
I rung the doorbell.
I clearly heard her
running up to the door!
- To look?
- To look in the peephole.
- You should have put your
thumb on the peephole.
- Yeah, and I guarantee,
the moment that she looked
at the peephole and gaijin
she was like, oh hell no.
I'm not going out there,
are you kidding me?
So immediately I was like, okay.
I have that kind of neighbor.
Well, whatever.
And then, yeah,
I immediately knew.
It didn't say in this letter,
it didn't say--
- [Connor] Who it was.
- Who it was,
but, man.
She must have not thought this through,
because in the letter she said,
I always hear you guys stomping around.
So I'm like, well,
clearly you live below me.
You're not even hiding it now!
And she's like, yeah,
your stomping is so loud in the night
that I'm getting insomnia.
And I'm just like, okay?
I mean, sorry?
Like, you must hate me then,
in my previous place,
because I was up till fucking 4AM.
I'm living a normal
fucking life in this place.
Yeah, and she kept sending me it,
and I'm just like, oh my God.
What am I gonna do with this woman?
So the moment she sent this recent letter,
like a couple of weeks ago?
I was like, you know what?
I'm gonna fucking show this woman,
'cause I'm getting fucking annoyed.
Because she threatened to, like--
- Burn down her apartment.
(laughing)
- So I unscrewed the hinges in her door.
- I broke down her door.
- And threw poop at it.
(laughing)
I shat in her mailbox.
- Honestly, honestly would have got her.
I'm joking.
- No, so I was like,
I'm gonna show this woman.
'Cause, like,
clearly by writing, by typing,
not even handwriting.
By typing out a clearly Google
translated letter to me,
she obviously thinks, like,
oh, these fucking dumb arse
foreigners don't know anything.
And there's this mentality of
xenophobic Japanese people,
usually very senile,
who think that they can get their way
because they're a senile Japanese person,
and we're just a dumb foreigner
who doesn't know the rules.
So I'm just like, alright.
I'll show them.
So I wrote a handwritten
letter, in Japanese,
in the most Keigo as fuck, like.
- Businessman Japanese.
- Yeah, the most polite Japanese
that you could ever see.
I might as well have written
a fucking invitation letter,
like a resume--
- To the King.
- To the King, right?
And so I wrote it down,
and I basically said I'm
sorry but we gotta do it,
because I work sometimes late at night,
and we're not trying to
be noisy or whatever,
and it's like,
and I basically said at
the bottom, I was like,
rather than you taking it to the housing
company and try and threaten me,
maybe we should talk face to face?
Which is basically the most passive
aggressive way of saying come at me,
bitch.
Fucking meet me outside.
Like, come at me.
- I've been to your
house, you don't stomp.
- [Joey] No, we don't!
- You walk like pretty normal--
- And it was really rude as well.
She wrote down being like,
your footsteps sound like you are
dropping an iron ball onto the ground.
- I saw the Google translated letter.
- And I was just like, fuck you?
Like what the fuck?
It's not like we're fucking neanderthals,
and just stomping around
in our apartments, right?
- Me, me.
- Fucking monkeying around.
- Tik Tok dance.
(laughing)
- Yeah, so I sent that.
I went down, I put it in her letterbox.
Surprise, surprise,
she hasn't complained since.
She never took it to the housing company
because I guarantee the
moment she read that letter,
she was like, oh shit.
He ain't a gaijin.
He's a nihonji.
- You just slam dunked a
senile with some Japanese.
- I was just like, I fucking got that.
I had to do it to her.
- When I introduced myself
to the neighbors as well,
the one to the,
so I'm on the end, which is great,
'cause where I film is also on
the end that is just nothing.
- [Joey] Like window?
- Yeah, so it's great.
I can be loud during the day and whatever.
So the neighbors to the
right of me weren't in,
and so we went to go
to the neighbors below,
and, Mailin,
you remember this story, right?
When we went to say hi
to the neighbors below?
- Oh yeah.
'Cause you went with him, didn't you?
- No, you weren't there.
You weren't there, okay.
So I went to say hi to them below,
and so I was with someone from Geeks Plus
and the housing agent person,
and they pressed the ringer--
- [Joey] Doorbell.
- The doorbell.
- [Joey] The ringer!
- The thing that goes brr.
(laughing)
They pressed it and, you know,
they start speaking in Japanese,
and they start having a conversation,
and slowly I see the two
Japanese women with me looking
slowly more and more displeased
at what's being said.
And if I remember correctly,
what was roughly translated was like, oh,
my husband doesn't let me talk
to foreigners without him there,
or something?
And I was like,
and the housing company
woman was like, I'm so sorry.
I'm so sorry.
They're like, don't worry about it.
They're just old, or whatever.
I was like, oh.
Great, what a warm welcome to Japan.
My husband won't let
me talk to foreigners?
Like, Jesus Christ.
What am I gonna do?
I'm like Mike Wazowski at the door,
like, what are they saying?
What's being said?
- What are they gonna
do, shit in my mailbox?
- They're like,
I hear they shit through
mailbox with pumpkins?
- These dirty foreigners.
- He's gonna break my
door down apparently.
- I'd laugh if they were just
actually talking the maddest shit.
The translator was just like, yeah,
she just doesn't.
- Yeah, it's like when you
see those interpreters that,
like, don't tell the joke?
I wouldn't be surprised, I mean.
I wish I, you know,
could understand Japanese
at the level I can now.
Maybe I would have picked it up--
- She's like, I wish death upon him.
The translators like,
she's feeling unwell.
(laughing)
- It was probably something like that.
- Yeah, it was probably
something like that.
- But, I mean,
I bump into my other
neighbors all the time,
and they're pretty chill.
They always say hi to me, so.
- Yeah, my neighbors next
to me are this really
old couple who used to live in LA,
so their English is actually pretty good.
- That's cool.
- And that's good,
because Aki isn't the most
proficient in Japanese, right?
But they obviously know that,
and so every time they meet on the stairs.
It was really weird because, like,
I was walking to my local supermarket
and my neighbor walked past,
and it was really weird
because I was expecting,
you know, like a very
traditional Japanese,
like, ah,
Konnichiwa, kind of thing.
But instead--
- Yo, whattup?
- What up, mate?
- No, instead she was like,
how you going?
(laughing)
A really weirdly Australian
British accent as well?
And I'm like, I thought
you said you lived in LA?
That doesn't sound very Los Angeles like?
And yeah, I was just like,
oh, oh hi.
I guess?
'Cause I was fully expecting
to do the whole bow thing,
right?
But she was just like, 'sup?
- Some old people are
really fucking nice here,
and they love speaking to you.
- [Joey] Yeah.
- And then other times, like,
they just want you dead.
- [Joey] Yeah!
- I guess that's just old people
everywhere with foreigners,
right, though?
So that's not only Japanese--
- But I think Japan takes it
to a whole other level, right?
- It seems like one extreme or the other.
- It's hard for me to say.
I mean, I'm White,
and grew up in a white place,
so I don't know--
- I mean, in England,
nobody talks to each other
or acknowledges each other.
- Generally, talking is frowned upon.
- Yeah.
(laughing)
- In capacity.
- I remember, actually,
the first time I went to America,
I was in New York,
and this was my very first
experience in America,
'cause I'd pretty much
only been in England,
and basically Europe, and Thailand.
So I remember I was standing
in the lift of my hotel,
and this American,
there was one other person in the lift,
and she asked me, so,
how are you doing today?
You having a good day?
And me, as a British person,
I fucking freeze up.
Like, I don't know how to act!
I'm like, are you picking a fight with me?
(laughing)
What the fuck's going here?
What do you want from me?
Are you trying to sell something?
Because in England you
don't talk to each other.
Everyone stands there in awkward silence
and doesn't acknowledge each other,
and we go about our day.
- I had the same thing
in Canada, on a bus,
I was 17 maybe?
I was on a bus, and the guy said,
like, great weather,
I'm not doing the accent.
- [Garnt And Joey] Yeah.
- Great weather today.
And I just ignored him.
(laughing)
'Cause I didn't think
he was talking to me.
And then he was like,
not much of a talker, hey?
And then I did, like,
you know how Elle stares
at Light in The Thing?
I was like.
(laughing)
Like, you talking to me?
- I actually did exactly the same thing,
because she talks over to me,
and the first thing I did was check
if there was someone behind me.
I was like.
- Yeah, in the UK it's just not a thing.
You don't talk to people in public.
And I remember thinking, like,
oh, uh.
Yeah.
Yeah, like,
what do you want?
Like?
Do you want money?
- Are you begging?
- You're just like a deer in headlights.
You just don't know what to do!
- I know better now.
- Yeah.
- I had the craziest fucking Elevator,
I don't even know if I'm allowed
to fucking talk about this one.
- We can cut it.
- We can cut it if it's too extreme.
- I mean, it's not the extreme situation.
It's what the guy said.
- So he's got a shit in a pumpkin.
(laughing)
- No, so it was my first time in LA ever,
and it was Anime Expo, obviously,
'cause why else would you go to LA?
And I was in the hotel, you know.
Aki was there--
- I have elevator stories from LA now.
They're just flashing--
- It's always LA, man.
It's always LA.
But, you know,
my Japanese side is always like
if you're just in the
elevator by yourself,
then you can just be rowdy, and have fun,
and talk to your friends
and everybody, right?
But the moment someone
you don't know comes in,
you gotta behave, you gotta quiet down,
because you don't want to
inconvenience them, right?
(laughing)
I've told you guys this story.
- Yeah.
- So it was me, Aki,
and like a few other people we knew.
And we were going down in the elevator,
obviously just chatting it up, whatever.
Elevator stops halfway.
Door opens, and this Black guy walks in.
Don't know him, right?
So immediately I was like, oh shit,
someone's, you know,
coming into the elevator--
- Let's stop clowning around.
- Yeah, yeah.
Let's stop clowning around, you know.
We don't want to inconvenience him.
He walks in really quietly.
Door closes, starts going down,
and then he just goes, oh yeah,
everybody shuts up when
the N word walks in.
(laughing)
And I was just like,
I didn't know whether
to say sorry or like?
'Cause if I said sorry
then we would mean that?
But I couldn't say anything!
I couldn't even be like, ahh!
(laughing)
So I was just like, eyes darting.
Just being like, what
am I supposed to say?
It's like what are you
supposed to say to that,
in that situation?
And I was like, man,
America's fucking terrifying.
I'm taking the escalator from now on.
- I've never felt more
complimented in my life
than when I went into an elevator in LA,
and there was, like,
I think there was a bunch of women.
There must have been five or six of them,
and they were all mid 40's.
I don't know what they were doing.
And they were just saying something,
and then they asked me a question,
and I just responded,
and then when they heard
my voice they were like,
oh damn!
(laughing)
Where are you from?
And I was like, oh,
I'm from the UK,
and they're like, what do you do?
I was like, I'm a voice actor,
and they're like, yeah.
Yeah you are.
(laughing)
I was like, oh no.
I am in danger.
(laughing)
But I was so flattered,
that gave me the confidence
boost I needed that day.
I was like, hell yeah.
I'm ready for this panel.
- When you were in America
with the British accents.
- [Connor] Yeah, yeah.
- With any accent that's not American.
- Yeah, yeah,
and I think because I
have a deep voice as well,
it's just the perfect--
- 'Cause I get that all the time too.
Like, every time I go to
a Starbucks or whatever,
and I order something.
I remember I went to a
Starbucks once in Vegas,
and I said, I don't remember
when I fucking ordered.
I was like, can I get a mocha frappuccino,
or whatever,
and the girl's like, say that again?
(laughing)
And I'm like, and I
thought she didn't hear me!
So I was like, can I
get a mocha frappuccino?
And she's like, your accent's so nice,
I'm gonna have to hear that one more time.
(laughing)
- I think I would die inside.
I'd be like--
- And I'm just like,
there's people fucking staring at me.
I'm just like,
I just want a fucking mocha frappuccino.
Just give it to me please.
So now every time I go to a
Starbucks I'm so afraid of that,
so I just--
- You don't order the mocha frappuccino.
- Yeah.
No, I just do my best to
do an American accent.
And they never fucking question me.
- Americano please.
- Yeah, I'm just like,
can I get a latte,
and they're just like, yeah,
okay, which one do you want?
- Do you ever play up your
accent more in the US?
- Um.
- I fucking turn that
shit on like a hundred.
- Yeah, sometimes I do if I
want to get out of a situation,
where I just start fucking talking,
like, bogan Australian sometimes,
where it gets to the
point where they clearly
don't understand what the fuck I'm saying,
and I'm just like, (inaudible yelling).
- I'm out, I'm out.
- Do you ever go that, Garnt?
Do you ever turn up your British accent?
- Um, I mean.
- I go like full fucking Downton
Abbey in America sometimes.
- [Garnt] Really?
- Cause they fucking eat it up, dude.
Like if I really want
them to be nice to me,
like the waiter, you know,
if I want good service, you know?
I'll be like, thank you so much,
that's amazing, wow.
(laughing)
Wow, thank you.
This food is delicious.
You did a great job.
Oh my gosh.
- And they're just like, oo.
- I must sound like such
a fucking asshole though.
It's fun, it's fun man.
People are so nice to me--
- Use it to your advantage, man.
- I guess so, yeah.
And then I remember that
Americans would ask me,
they're like,
do you guys see American accents the way
that we see British accents?
And I'm like, no.
(laughing)
Not at all, not at all.
- Oh, as in attractive?
- Yeah, yeah,
yeah, like,
they were like,
'cause I remember one time I,
the way I explained it to him,
I was like, if there's an
American on public transport,
everyone knows.
(laughing)
Everyone knows and they
know you're American--
- They're usually the loudest.
- Yeah, they know.
They know, they hate it.
'Cause we're so, like,
everything we consume
obviously is American media.
We consume so much American stuff,
so we're so desensitized
to American media,
and obviously to American's,
it's like a, oo,
it's a flavor of British.
Hogwarts is interesting.
- Very international.
- I think it's also because we've been to
America so often now for conventions.
'Cause I remember back
in high school, or--
- But I think even general British people
aren't impressed by American's accents.
- I mean, I remember back in university,
whenever someone had an American accent
they would definitely stand out.
Maybe less so now,
because I think there's more American's
coming over to England to study to here.
- Yeah, we had that one American
exchange student in our high school,
and everybody fucking loved it.
They were like,
keep talking, keep talking!
- Maybe things have changed.
I don't know, man.
At least in my university,
no one gave a shit.
- I mean, I definitely,
I mean, we're all used to them,
but I think Garnt and I are definitely
used to it because we
live with an American.
- Yeah, right.
I'm definitely used to it now--
- Yeah, yeah,
yeah.
- But before then, it was definitely,
I do think it was more exotic before I--
- Because I remember American
accents sounding so harsh.
Like, you could clearly hear the hard R.
Like, I mean.
(laughing)
- Yo, what is Aki saying?
Aki canceled?
(laughing)
- The hard R in every
word that has an R in it.
Not just the single word,
every word that has an R in it.
Because we don't pronounce
the R's in all of our words,
right?
So when we hear the R, like the rrr sound,
I'm just like--
- Ew, ew,
ew, ew.
- Oh God, why?
Stop, please.
- Hearing Americans say British
swear words is the most disgusting thing--
- Yeah, we've said this.
Yeah.
- We talked about cunt
in a previous podcast,
but hearing sometimes
Sydney would say wanker.
- Oh my God, I hate that.
- No.
There's some British words that
should never be said by an American.
Wanker, bellend.
I don't even want to hear
an American say bellend.
- Bellend, oh.
I mean, we don't even
say that in Australia.
- No, and we have a bunch of British ones,
you guys have Australian ones.
- But like, oh my God.
The first time I heard
an American say wanker,
I was like, speaking of wanker,
fucking this guy?
- The one that I hear sometimes Americans
say that I'm like please don't?
They're like, twart.
I'm like, it's twat.
Don't say it, please.
Have you ever had any, like,
you know, because you
both have American GF's,
right?
Have you had any weird things,
like, cultural difference
that you've stumbled across,
where you're like, why do you do this?
- I mean, I didn't have it with Aki,
but as I mentioned earlier,
my first couple of YouTube
friends were Americans, right?
And before then I didn't really
have international friends.
All of my friends were
just Aussies, basically.
And so, like,
when you speak a lot of, like,
especially Australian slang, right?
Which is pretty much a different
language in and of itself.
In your head, you're just like,
oh yeah, this is just a
universal word that you use.
So I remember saying a bunch of slang
to my American YouTuber friends,
like I don't know if you guys say arvo?
- No, that's Australian.
- That's definitely Australian.
- That's too uncivilized.
(laughing)
- It's peasant's language.
- Un-ironically peasant.
- Yeah, so we say,
you know, instead of
five in the afternoon,
we say five in the arvo.
- You're just cutting out stuff
that doesn't need to be cut out.
Like, it's?
- Afternoon is too long of a word!
- Oh my God.
- Just say arvo,
it's two syllables?
- That's got more than four letters?
No thank you.
- And so I said like, you know,
obviously my American friends were like,
what time is it in Australia right now?
And I'm just like, oh,
it's like three in the arvo.
And they're like, three in the arvo?
What's an arvo?
And I'm like, oh my God.
They don't say arvo?
So I was like, three in the afternoon.
Do you understand?
And they're like, oh yeah,
yeah, yeah.
In the afternoon.
- Do you understand?
Are you YouTuber?
(laughing)
- It's been really funny seeing how,
like, when I first joined the internet,
the British accent was praised,
and now it's just memed to shit.
- [Joey] Yeah.
- Like everyone's like chews-day.
Chews-day innit.
- You-chube, You-chube.
- Watah, watah.
- It's 'cause I think
American's only thought that,
like, the Southern,
you know, (inaudible) English.
- The posh Southern accent.
- And then they realized that
90% of the UK sounds disgusting.
(laughing)
It actually does.
My dad's from Liverpool
and when I go to go there,
I'm like, I hate this.
- They speak a different
language over there.
The more Northern,
I'm gonna insult the
fucking North now because--
- I love the North, but
some of the accents I hate.
- Some, the more further North you go,
the more I'm like.
- Up into Scotland.
(laughing)
- Up to Scotland.
The more I'm like, man.
I know we're speaking the same language,
but for some reason I cannot understand
what we're saying even though we're both
apparently speaking English right now.
- I remember we were
watching a TV show with Aki,
and there was dudes from Yorkshire?
And me and you were having no
problem understanding them,
and Aki was like, is there subtitles?
I can't understand what they're saying.
- Dude, I showed her
Monty Python's Holy Grail,
and she was like, I need
to put subtitles on.
(laughing)
She was just like,
I legitimately can't
understand what this--
- That's good accents though?
They're clean.
- And she was like,
no, no,
it's 'cause it's an old
movie and the audio is bad.
I'm like, it's got nothing to do with the,
I can hear it fine!
But one thing I will
never fucking understand,
I'm sure a lot of Americans
will understand this,
but, like,
when you say to an American
what is the sexiest accent?
Like, what is an accent that you
want people to whisper into your ear?
For some reason, Australian
accent is always the top.
And I'm just like what
the fuck are you on about?
Australian accents are fucking disgusting.
- Australian's on bottom three for me.
- It's like you're only
thinking Australian accent
because you're thinking
of Chris Hemsworth,
right?
Like yeah,
of course everyone wants Chris Hemsworth
to whisper into their ear.
- Of course, of course.
- But Chris Hemsworth is the
point 001% of Australians.
- As is every British actor.
- Yeah, right?
And it's like,
I think I saw an article that
was the top three are Australian,
British, and Irish.
- Scottish is pretty good too.
- Scottish is pretty.
Like I understand Scottish and Irish?
I think that's kind of cute as well?
- I like Scottish and Irish.
- Yeah, Scottish and irish are really,
really nice, right?
But I hear the majority
of British accents,
and the Australian accent,
I'm just like, no.
I can't.
- I grew up in the North,
and I was surrounded by those accents.
- [Garnt And Joey] Yeah.
- And that's why I get
mocked when I go back.
They're like, you're not from here?
(laughing)
- You definitely don't sound
like the area that you're from.
- No, no--
- And I don't know if that
evolved over the time?
- It did.
If you go back to my
very first YouTube video,
I sound like someone from
the area that I grew up in.
- Oh yeah, when I first met you,
you had quite a heavy Welsh accent.
- Yeah, I wasn't even Welsh.
It was more Northern, but,
'cause the Welsh accent
sounds like this, you know?
They talk like this and I
never sounded like this,
but everyone in my
village talked like this.
- But you definitely didn't
sound like you do now.
- No, no,
I didn't.
I sounded more just like
general Northern English.
- 'Cause I've lost my accent quite a bit.
People say, like.
When I look back at old
video's I'm like, ew.
It's so strong--
- I think because you
really iron out your,
you enunciate a lot more?
- Yeah, I think it's
just the YouTuber accent.
Right?
Where you have to stop mumbling
and start paying attention
to what you're saying,
because people from all different
races are gonna be listening to you.
- Because the word 'literally'?
In Australia we say litrally.
- Yeah, that's how we say it--
- But I can't say litrally anymore,
I have to say literally.
(laughing)
I don't know why?
And my dad gave me so much shit
for it the last time I was home.
He was like, what the fuck did you say?
Literally?
You sound like a fucking American, mate.
He was like, say litrally
like a true Aussie.
I'm like, alright.
Thank you for your patriotism, dad.
- I got accused on one of the comments.
They were like, Connor isn't from Wales.
Connor.
I'm from where Connor is,
no one speaks like that.
That's fake.
And it just didn't cross their mind
that your accent can evolve.
- [Garnt] Yeah, exactly.
- I think there was a study that was
done in Antarctica where they sent,
you know when the scientists go?
And they wanted to see, from
all the European scientists,
what would happen to their accents
over the three month period,
and normally they would
all, for some reason,
pick up one persons accent the most,
and they would generally
start to talk the way did.
And I think that's how it is.
You can quickly change
your accent if you're not
surrounded by people who sound the same.
- And I think that's why I've lost
my accent a lot of the times,
because I have spent, just from what I do,
I've spent more time
with the non Aussies--
- Yeah, I spent a lot of time in London.
And spent a ton of time in Japan,
a ton of time around Americans.
- There's words I pick up from,
you know, British English
and American English.
It kind of just becomes
a conglomerate of just
a bunch of different
languages and accents, right?
- It's just kind of a mixture
of internet language as well,
another one that I'm into so often--
- Pretty much, yeah.
- I'm sure if I moved back to England,
my accent would morph slowly back
into more of a British accent.
- I have noticed that, though.
When I go back to Australia and I talk
to my high school friends or whatever?
I just immediately kick into Australian.
I remember when I met Rubber Ninja, Ross.
You know, he's an Aussie right?
- [Connor] Yeah.
- But he's been living
in America for so long
that his natural accent
is just American now.
But I remember the first
time I met him at AX,
the moment he heard my accent he was like,
oi yeah, mate.
Just fucking, like.
He just completely changed to an Aussie,
and I was just like,
you could talk like this the entire time
and I reckon more people would be into it.
- Yeah, that happened to me
when I went back to Wales.
I definitely regained
some of my older accent.
Which I didn't like.
I don't like my old accent.
I prefer this one.
I like the way I speak clearly, you know?
- [Joey] More concisely, yeah.
- It's more of a voice acting accent.
- Yeah, it's more generalized,
and it allows me to say words easy.
- Mm.
- Before I struggled with words.
(laughing)
So, you know.
- So then I'm curious how,
like since you guys have
moved to Japan, right?
Like, about your lifestyle changes.
I think it's 'cause doing YouTube here
I feel is completely different to doing
YouTube anywhere else in the world.
- Yeah.
- Yep.
- I don't know if it's 'cause we have
an agency here that keeps up in check?
'Cause I'm my own worst enemy,
and if I can be lazy, I will be lazy.
- [Garnt] Yeah, yeah.
- So having an agency has
really helped me, like,
just stay responsible, you know?
'Cause I don't want to let them down.
- [Joey] Right, right,
right.
- Not that I was letting
myself down anyway.
But I doubly don't want to fuck up,
because Mailin will kill me.
(laughing)
And also having Japanese
class two times a week,
that I have to be there by nine.
So I have to be awake
at 7:30 to get there?
- Which you did this morning by the way.
- Yeah, which I did this morning.
- Which you do every
morning before we record--
- I do it every morning
before we record the podcast,
so I basically have no choice
but to maintain a healthy lifestyle.
Before Coronavirus shit,
I was going gym five times a week.
I was so hyped for that
and now I don't care.
- Yeah, no.
'Cause I don't want to go to a gym
and fucking have to run
in a mask or anything.
It's just not working.
And you can't even do it outside anymore
because its like 35 fucking degrees,
and 80% humidity.
- I just don't.
Every time I've been working out recently,
I'm like, it's just shit.
I'm not doing a good job.
- It just feels bad,
where you'd be making such good progress
and then you'd have to
take out two months off.
You go back to the gym, and you're--
- I was getting so many gains, bro.
My arms were getting beautiful.
- Yeah, we're all going
to the gym together,
and it was just, yeah.
It's just sad now that that's the case.
- But overall, other than that.
I mean, like,
it's, I don't know what exactly it is.
If it's just the different
time zone that's forced me to.
I can't talk to Americans
as much as I used to.
I have to take care of myself.
I eat better here just because
there's more healthy options.
Like,
the whole thing where you,
like, you know,
why are people so thin in Japan?
It's just because the healthier
food is more readily available,
and you walk a shit ton.
- You really have to search
for crap food here, right?
- I don't think you do.
- You don't, but there's--
- Like go to the combini,
and half the shit in there
will make you fat as fuck.
- I guess, but.
- It's just like whereas
in the UK it was like
you had to pay a lot and
find the healthy food,
it's like it's equally distributed,
where it's like you can
have extremely healthy food,
and right next to it is the bad stuff,
and it's not a question of can I get it,
it's do I want to get the healthy food.
- Yeah.
It's not like in America,
where like, you know,
a McDonald's is readily available
five minutes down the road.
You have to fucking look up,
you have to go deep on Yelp
to find a vegan restaurant.
- I mean, that's the TLDR
of why I think people are thin in Japan.
Walk a fuck ton,
and there's way healthier foods,
way more readily available.
- It's just a lifestyle
thing where people,
because you're surrounded by people
who have a much healthier lifestyle,
it kind of goads you into having
a more healthy lifestyle as well.
- Yeah,
because everyone else around
you is not eating like shit,
and not sitting indoors all day, right?
Like when I order a Domino's Pizza,
and then Joey's like, yeah,
I had a salad.
I'm like, fuck.
I mean, chill out--
- You mean last night?
(laughing)
Smashed a Matsuya last night?
- Dude, Matsuya's my
favorite place on Earth.
It's the best.
- Connor, do you want to explain Matsuya?
- So there's three beef bowls--
- There's the big three, basically.
- The big three of beef bowls,
and just general meat and rice,
like fast food chains.
- So there's Matsuya, Yoshinoya,
and, oh my God,
what's the third one?
- Uh, Sukiya?
- Sukiya, that's it.
Sukiya.
- Everyone on the vlog
channels will be like,
go to Yoshinoya!
Like, no.
Don't go to Yoshinoya.
Let me tell you why Matsuya's
the best, straight up.
First of all, in Yoshinoya,
you have to speak to people.
I don't like that.
You have to tell the person what you want.
I'm not for that.
I like it when the machine takes my order,
and I give the man the ticket,
and I don't say anything.
I just get my meal, right?
I love that, first of all.
There's an English option as well.
Not that like, you know,
everything should have an English option.
I'm not here for that,
I'm just saying that
it's nice that I don't
have to worry when I'm eating.
'Cause sometimes in
Japan you're just like,
fuck, man,
I just want to order without
having to shit myself.
- Japan makes it,
a lot of places in Japan make it very easy
just to not have human interaction.
- Which I appreciate so much.
- Which, as a British person?
That's fan-fucking-tastic.
What I hate though, also
as a British person,
in any restaurant in Japan,
if they don't have a button
that calls the waiter to you,
you have to call them yourself.
And so in England the etiquette is that
you try to be as quiet as possible.
You look for eye contact, okay?
You look for, okay,
excuse me, yeah.
- Even the hand, the hand's a risky move.
- Oh yeah, even the hand.
- You're kind of making
a scene there in British.
- It's a lot of this.
It's like.
- Yeah, yeah,
yeah, yeah.
Like, you want the bill?
It's like, ah.
And that's as much as you do
to get a waiter's attention.
In Japan, you gotta shout out.
You gotta shout at the top of your lungs.
(shouting in foreign language)
- Dude, Korean's are laughing
their ass off right now.
Like, ha,
these peasant's don't know how to shout.
But the worst part is, like,
me and Garnt will go, like,
I'll go full volume, like
(shouting in foreign language),
and then silence.
Joe will go (whispering
in foreign language),
and then they'll just.
(muttering)
They're coming over at the speed of light.
I'm like, what the fuck?
- Yeah, I don't get that,
'cause, like,
last week we went to
an Izakaya afterwards.
Like after we finished recording.
And because it's the Izakaya
that doesn't have the button,
so Connor and Garnt were
just like (groans loudly),
with this shit again.
It's like self fulfilling
prophecy the moment you sit down,
right?
- It's like I know it's okay to shout
publicly to get their attention,
but my body has been crafted over 20--
- It's conditioned, yeah.
- To never, ever,
ever make any public disturbance.
- Oh no, it's the same
in Australia as well.
I remember the first couple
of years I lived here,
like, I never did it.
I always just kind of did this.
a lot of eye contact, like nodding scene?
- 'Cause in Japan,
they just don't want to make eye contact.
They do everything to avoid eye contact,
so doing that's impossible.
So every time I have to shout out,
I die a little inside.
- I think my life expectancy
goes down by a few months
every time I (speaking
in foreign language).
And especially if it fails.
- Yeah. (laughs quickly)
- But then have you ever had the pity one,
where I've said it, like
(shouting in foreign language),
and then they will ignore me,
but one of the customers
will have heard me,
and he'll go like (speaking
in foreign language),
and he'll point to me and go,
like, he wants your attention.
- [Garnt] No, I've never had that.
- Fuck.
I'm white as fuck, dude.
He's like, I'll help the foreigner out.
I'll give him a dub.
But anyway, back to Matsuya,
the best place in Japan.
You basically can get a banger of a meal
that fills you up to brim for,
like, eight bucks maybe?
Less if you want to get the cheaper ones?
Like even less.
The set I go for?
It's like you get this, like,
oh, it's amazing.
This grilled ginger pork and rice.
You get a tater salad, you got a ton-jiro,
which is like miso soup
with extra shit in it.
It's amazing, I fucking love that shit.
It's so clean--
- But you can get a regular
beef ball with all of that for,
like, 600 yen.
- Yeah, for nothing.
If you want to go ham, you can get it,
and you can--
- It's less than 10 bucks.
- You can double that bitch up as well
for an additional two bucks,
and it's like a whole pig?
It's amazing, I love it.
(laughing)
Every time I come in they're like,
shit, Connor's coming in.
Get the whole pig carcass out, like.
'Cause I'll max everything,
'cause I'm like, I want meat and rice.
I'm there, it's so good.
And in Yoshinoya you get these
pathetic little ball sizes?
Like, what am I gonna do--
- No, I like Sukiya.
- Okay, Yoshinoya and Sukiya are good.
I just think Matsuya's the best.
- Oh yeah,
yeah, yeah.
But that's because you don't
order what they specialize in.
- No.
- You get the side menu shit, right?
- I mean, yeah.
I guess so.
- Because in terms of actual beef balls,
like, udons,
I reckon Sukiya and Yoshinoya
have it better than Matsuya.
- Man.
- Just saying.
- We're gonna make a fucking Japanese
fast food tier list here, man.
(laughing)
- I'd be down for that.
- We should do a video of,
one of the, you can go Sukiya,
you can go to Yoshinoya,
I'll go to Matsuya,
and I'll be like, this is what you get--
- We just argue which one's the best.
- But we'll take each other to each chain,
and then we'll be like,
this is what we're getting.
- This is the best one.
- [All] Yeah.
- I remember this one time,
I went to this very
local place with Sydney,
'cause this is when we were
staying outside of Japan?
Oh, not outside of,
outside of Tokyo,
so I was a bit more in the countryside.
So we went in this, we were craving ramen,
so we were looking for
a local ramen place.
And we go to this place.
Obviously neither of
us can speak Japanese,
or read it too well,
so we go to this place and the entire
menu is handwritten in Kanji.
- Hell yeah.
Hell, I love that,
'cause I've learnt the Kanji,
the numbers, I'm like (inaudible) brain.
- But we have to kind of try
to figure out what everything is.
And so we go, we pick something that's,
you know, looks reasonable.
Because we were looking at the price,
and the price was about 1300 yen,
which is about 13 bucks,
forgetting that in Japan, like,
ramen is cheap in Japan.
It's super, super cheap.
And we were ordering something that was,
like, 13 bucks when it should have cost--
- In the middle of nowhere.
- Yeah, in the middle of nowhere.
- Should be, like,
seven, 800 yen?
- Yeah, when it should be
about seven or 800 yen.
And we forgot that.
And I remember we ordered it,
and the waiter just looks at us.
And I think he was asking are you sure?
He was like, are you sure you want this?
You want this one?
Two of them, for both of you?
- You should have known that that point.
- Yeah, yeah.
We just want ramen, yeah.
We want it.
So he goes back,
he says something to the chef,
and the chef's eyes just goes.
Okay.
(laughing)
He was just like, oh,
you serious, you serious?
- They get both their keys
out and unlock the safe.
- Crack the neck.
- So what comes out is they
bring us this extra large ramen,
and then with it was just
this extra large beef ball.
And then he brings out one of them,
puts it in front of me,
and I just think, I've
made a massive mistake.
(laughing)
I look at Sydney.
Sydney's just staring at this ball,
being like--
- That's coming, that's coming!
- Sydney's like, we ordered two of those.
One each.
'Cause it would be impossible
for one of us to finish this,
let alone two of us
finishing both of them.
And so he brings it over to Sydney,
and I don't know what the etiquette
is if you don't finish your food,
but we fucking tried to
devour as much as we can.
We don't even get through half of it.
- Oh my God.
- And we feel so fucking bad.
And we're getting the bill,
it was the most shameful bill of all time.
I'm like, it's,
(speaking in foreign language).
- He's like, are you sure about that?
Are you sure?
- Okay bitch.
- We didn't even make
a fucking dent in this.
- Oh my God.
I have never experienced
that because I would rather
behead myself that leave
food in a Japanese place.
I don't know why I'm so scared of it?
Like one time, in Matsuya funnily enough,
I accidentally ordered two
of the double L sized sets?
- [Joey] Right.
- Which is like--
- Way too much food for one person.
- I think it's near 4000 calories.
Like it is a mountain of rice.
And I don't know how I actually did this,
I should have realized by how much I paid,
and it came,
and I was like, fuck.
I wasn't even that hungry.
I was like, shit.
So I forced this inside of me,
and I was, when I got home I threw up.
But in the restaurant I was like,
if you can imagine a dude,
literally like if his esophagus was full,
I was literally like.
(laughing)
Like drinking the miso
soup to push it down.
You know what I mean?
I was like, give me more water.
I need to push this shit down with water.
It was horrible.
I thought I was gonna die.
They must have been looking at me,
like, at me crying at a Matsuya,
like why is he still eating it?
- That's just the most
British thing I've ever heard.
Would rather throw up
from eating too much food
than feel the shame of
leaving food on the plate.
- Yeah, I would rather
throw up in an alleyway
than order way too much, clearly,
and then have to give them it back,
and be like, throw it away.
- [Garnt] Yeah.
- Yeah, okay,
was it very unhealthy and
extremely questionable?
Yeah, but sometimes you have
to make a decision in life.
- But I got the respect
from those Matsuya--
- When I say (speaking
in foreign language),
I fucking meant that shit.
(laughing)
I'm walking out like.
Oh God.
My bowls stacked on top of each other.
I'd never eaten that much food in my life.
- I'll tell you the one
place I don't feel shameful
for leaving food on the plate though,
and that's whenever I go to America.
- Oh yeah, yeah,
yeah--
- And just witness the food
sizes there for everything.
- I had that in fucking Chicago
when I was at Con+Alt+Delete.
- I'm sure it's no surprise
to Americans that their
food portions are--
- Yeah, and I'm just like,
I had that in Chicago when I ordered
deep dish pizza for the first time,
and because we'd never ordered it, right,
and most of us never ordered it,
we were like, oh yeah,
it's just the same as a regular pizza.
There's like, what?
Seven of us there?
Yeah, we'll get five deep dish pizzas.
- It looks awful.
Am I crazy?
Does it taste terrible?
- It tastes good, but--
- It tastes great for the first slice.
- Yeah, but one slice is
like eating a whole pizza.
Basically.
Because it's literally just a whole pizza
just stacked on top of one slice.
- I've had the kind of deep ones,
but not like there where it looks like--
- Oh no, we had the fucking deep dish.
- It's basically a basin
for the sauce, right?
Like it's?
- It's a pizza lasagna, that's what is it.
- But at that point it's like the whole,
the best part of the pizza
is the synergy between--
- The synergy? (laughing)
- The synergy.
- What are you talking about?
- Bro, the way the bread,
the cheese and the sauce
is the perfect amount?
You get the best bite.
If there was one too
many of those elements--
- It's like a fucking pizza
theologist right here.
- Dude.
I'm telling you, man.
If there's too much sauce,
you got to drink the pizza.
What's up with that?
- I like the saucy pizza's though?
- [Garnt] Yeah, yeah.
- [Connor] No, no.
- Like the extra sauce pizza's.
But I will admit that deep dish was,
like, damn.
- Could you put a straw
in it and drink it?
- Probably.
- That shouldn't happen,
that shouldn't be possible--
- I mean, it goes in layers.
I didn't realize why so many Americans
called pizza's pies until
I had a deep dish pizza,
and I was like, oh,
this is a fucking pie.
- This is a pizza pie.
- Is that where it came from?
- Yeah, I think so?
- I'm not sure,
but I was definitely eating a pie
that was shaped like a pizza.
- A pizza flavored pie.
- Yeah, exactly.
- Pretty much, exactly.
- But I remember as well,
when I went to Texas for the first time,
and we went to, like,
I don't remember what the
Italian restaurant was,
but it was a big Italian restaurant.
And portion sizes in America--
- Olive Garden?
- No.
(laughing)
Portion sizes in America
are already big, right?
But in Texas it's hold my
beer levels on fucking food.
So we went to this Italian restaurant,
and it was Misty's birthday.
So we went to an Italian restaurant,
and we were getting all this food,
and, you know,
normally when you go in an
Italian restaurant anywhere,
right, it's like you order
one bowl of pasta each,
whatever you want.
Maybe share it around or whatever, no.
In this Italian restaurant it's like
one dish of pasta can feed an
Ethiopian family for a year.
Like, it is insane,
it's too much pasta.
And we thought that
was already ridiculous.
Like, we couldn't even finish that shit.
But then we wanted to order a cake, right?
And we saw, oh,
they sell tiramisu here.
And Misty's like, yeah,
I want a tiramisu!
And normally when you order cake
at a restaurant it's
like one slice, right?
- Yeah.
- No, they brought out
the whole fucking cake.
It was like.
(laughing)
It was legitimately this big!
This big and this deep.
- How much was it?
- It was like 20 bucks.
- What the fuck.
- And I was just like, I
think we ordered wrong?
And they were like, no,
there's only one tiramisu on the menu,
so it must mean this!
- Just ordering a cake.
- That's just like the only option
of anything is a crate of it.
Sometimes I just want a bit of it.
- And I'm just like?
And I thought like, oh,
you know, maybe it's a little bit.
Maybe it's like a really fancy tiramisu,
right, because of the price?
But I wasn't expecting
fucking grandma to bust
into the fucking
restaurant just being like,
here you go!
- Sometimes when I'm with
Americans in America,
and they're like, yeah,
that place is way too expensive.
You get ripped off.
And I'm like, bro,
I got enough to feed my whole family.
What do you mean?
In my head I'm like, mate,
you didn't get ripped off.
You been to France, bro?
You get one string of pasta and sauce,
and they charge you $20 for that shit.
- Would you like six snails for 20 euros?
- Yeah, I'm like?
In Europe, you don't
get that for that much.
It's rare, like,
I mean, to me,
yeah, LA was super expensive,
but I always got a shit
ton of food so I was fine.
- Yeah, exactly--
- I remember having to learn the hard way
that you just never order appetizers
when you go to an American restaurant,
'cause there's been--
- It's a meal.
- Yeah, because why would
you call it appetizers
when it's as big as the main course?
I don't get it.
In every other part of the world,
you order appetizer,
you have a three course meal sometimes,
you know, if you're feeling frisky.
In America you order
one thing off the menu,
and that one thing can feed
a fucking family for a week.
I swear to God.
- One thing I could never
fucking believe was the concept
of bottomless fries at
a fast food restaurant.
- Bottomless everything.
Already, like,
free refills was like a whoa concept,
because in Australia there's no fucking
restaurant that gives you free refills--
- [Connor] Yeah, same in all of Europe.
- Yeah, but I was like,
oh, it's free refills
and bottomless fries?
I'm like, what does bottomless fries mean?
- I just realized the
episode is like British
and Australian people discover America.
(laughing)
What's up with all of this stuff?
- Because I was so used to ordering
a large drink at a cinema,
right, like in Australia,
because, you know,
you could actually finish it.
A large drink in a fucking
American cinema's like they
might as well have just give
you four liters of coke.
- You just blew my mind,
I have another thing.
I found out in the cinema's in America,
you can refill your
popcorn in some of them.
- [Garnt And Joey] Yeah, yeah.
- I'm like, what?
No.
- Why is this allowed?
- I was like,
why did I buy the large then
if I can just refill it?
- Yeah, okay.
Here's a concept I can
never understand, right?
You go to any restaurant, right?
Usually it's free refills, right?
It's just a drink machine there.
But there's small,
medium, and large sized cups?
- Yeah, why would you not just
get the small and refill it?
- Why would you not just get a small cup?
And the I asked Aki,
and she's like, oh,
some people are just too lazy
to get up to get a refill.
- What?
(laughing)
- And I'm just like, are you?
It's like 20 cents extra, dude.
Are you really that lazy
that you'll just be like,
yeah, I'll pay a little bit
extra so I can sit for longer.
- All Americans are watching this.
Do you agree with the
points that we're making?
Are you frustrated that we don't--
- That's what I've heard
from another American,
and I've heard from multiple Americans.
- I don't get buttered popcorn.
I don't think it tastes good.
- I just don't eat while
I go to the cinemas.
- You don't?
It's like I have to eat.
- I maybe get like packet
of candy or something,
or whatever,
but I never get popcorn.
- I need popcorn when I go to the cinema,
or I don't want to do.
- I'm the guy who never actively
goes out and buys popcorn,
but when someone offers it,
I'm like, okay,
let me just chow down this shit.
- Yeah!
- Oh dude.
In my head it's like it's not the cinema
experience unless I get popcorn.
And that's probably because they've
conditioned me to think that way.
- [Joey] Right.
- I mean, I like it.
- Do you watch a movie at home,
and do you have to popcorn
when you're having it?
- No, no.
- So why do you have to
have it in the cinemas?
- Because I'm going
there, it's an experience.
I need to have the popcorn.
Maybe I don't need it.
- Maybe I've just been
conditioned from Australia,
because popcorn in Australian
cinemas was stupidly expensive.
- It was in the UK.
(laughing)
- Yeah, right?
And as a high school student it's like,
you can't afford--
- In high school I couldn't,
and I think 'cause maybe my parents
never ever wanted to buy it.
- Right, right.
- 'Cause you'd almost be
paying a fucking mortgage
to get the popcorn and drink set.
- It was like 10 pounds in the UK,
which is like,
nearly like, what?
14 dollars?
- Yeah, it was something like
that in Australia as well.
- Which is way more
than in America, right?
- Like a large popcorn in
Australian cinemas usually cost
more than the actual ticket
to go watch the movie.
- Yeah, it did in the UK.
- I'm just like, why?
I'll just go down to
the fucking supermarket
below and just sneak shit in?
It's so much cheaper--
- I don't know, it just
doesn't taste as good.
I don't know, man.
When you bring your own shit in,
it just tastes kind of flat, you know?
(laughing)
- I'm sorry, we peasants won't understand.
- You peasants wouldn't get it,
as a wealthy 1800's
Victorian lord of the land,
I must say.
- But no, in America,
did you ever go to an American cinema?
- Yeah I did--
- Where they would have, like,
so I went to a cinema in Wisconsin,
and they would just have
these butter machines
where you could just basically--
- Yeah, you could press it?
I was so confused.
- Press, pour as much butter
as you can on the popcorn.
- We had that.
In Vegas, we had one that had butter,
but also lard.
And I'm just like, ew--
- Lard?
- Yeah!
- Like pure fat?
- Mailin, is this a thing in your country?
- Yeah, they put--
- [Mailin] I've never seen that.
- I saw it,
it was in Vegas, in another state.
I saw.
- Why would you just
want to put lard on it?
- Because it makes it extra greasy.
- Americans, is this true?
- What is this?
- [Mailin] No.
- Yes, it is!
- Is this true?
- [Mailin] In Vegas?
- No, no,
no.
I saw it in another state too.
I don't think it's common
because I only saw it very,
very rarely?
But it was some kind of lardy,
fatty substance that was
sitting next to the butter.
I'm like, is butter
not fat enough for you,
that you need extra fat and
extra grease on your popcorn?
- I just, I remember I picked it up,
and I was like, ew,
my hands are oily?
- [Joey] Yeah!
- My hands shouldn't
be oily, it's popcorn?
- It was like touching the
back of an oven, right?
It was just gross.
- It was like the deep fried oil shit.
I'm like, what the fuck?
And I ruined my whole popcorn.
I put that shit on 'cause
everyone was doing it,
so I was like, alright,
it must taste good.
- And it's fucking horrible as well.
You can't put that shit on your lap
because then the grease starts
to seep through the bottom of the bucket--
- I didn't put that much on, luckily.
- [Mailin] (inaudible)
(laughing)
- Double it like this?
- While we're ranting
about American things?
Okay.
American cheese sauce.
- We're gonna lose all our subs.
- Okay, what is American spray--
- Ew!
- What is American spray cheese?
I'm just.
There's something that I don't
understand about America,
and then there's the spray cheese
that American's apparently love.
- I always thought the spray cheese shit
was just like shit
you'd see in the movies?
(laughing)
And then I went to Walmart
for the first time,
and I saw it,
and I'm like, it can't be?
- They're always like, no,
it tastes amazing on Cheez-its.
That's what they always say.
And I'm like, no,
it should never be in a can.
Or when they,
I remember I was at a thing
at someone's house in America,
and they were like, do
you want a grilled cheese?
I was like, oh,
I'd love a grilled cheese!
- [Garnt And Joey] Yeah!
- And then they gave it to me,
and I'm like, you put
the plastic shit on it?
You put the cheese singles, didn't you?
Yeah, that's the cheese.
I'm like, that's not cheese.
Look on the back, it's 4% cheese maximum!
I guarantee it, that's not cheese!
- Just because it says cheese flavoring,
it doesn't mean it's cheese!
- And I went to the
supermarket and there was,
like, a kilogram of cheddar
for $2 or something.
I'm like?
- You have proper cheese, why not use it?
Put it on your nachos.
- Yeah, because they were like,
it's too, I'm too lazy to cut it,
I think they told me?
And I'm like, get a knife?
(laughing)
What do you mean too lazy to cut it?
- Buy utensils.
- I literally would cut that shit,
like I would grab the block out of the,
just peel the wrapper,
and just cut it like that.
- Yeah!
- Yeah, yeah.
Like a normal human being.
- Why are you making this difficult?
America explain, explain.
- 'Cause I asked one of my American
friends when I saw it at the time.
I was like, what do you put this on?
Like, what does this thing--
- Burgers, burgers is
the only thing that I,
okay, I'll let you do.
- I was like, what is this--
- No, no.
It didn't even touch my burger.
- Yeah, no.
It's not gonna touch my burger.
- I don't want it but
I'll take it on a burger.
- No, I won't even take it on a burger.
- Yeah, but a Denny's,
or McDonald's.
It's all of those--
- I never get any cheesy at Denny's
or McDonald's in America.
- I don't give a shit on burgers.
Burgers is fine, I'm used to that.
- But I was like, what do
you put this spray cheese on?
And they were like, oh,
we don't put it on anything,
we just go like this
and put it in our mouth,
I'm just like, you are an absolute monkey.
- This is what, like,
you know we get a lot of
comments that were like,
why does Connor think Americans
are like another species?
- It's because you are!
- There's so many things, to me,
that as a British person
I'm just so baffled by
when American's explain it to me.
And yeah,
there's just so many things
where I'm just like, what?
- We're gonna offend so many
people with this podcast.
- America is another plant.
I love American's,
but there's just general life
stuff that's just like, what?
What?
- Every time I go to America,
I'm like, this is another planet.
I can't relate to these people.
- On a side note,
there's also so many fucking
things I love about America.
- Oh yeah, of course--
- There definitely are.
- I'm not gonna be like I'm
never gonna go back to America.
Of course I love America.
- I think I've never met
friendlier people than in America.
Like I love the UK, it's my home,
but damn, are people
fucking depressed there.
- Oh yeah.
(laughing)
- Dude, I get the best
elevator experience in America.
- No exactly!
You feel so fucking happy and
right talking to Americans,
and I'm like, man,
maybe they're onto something here.
- And we clown on their food,
but damn, man.
Some places, they give you
some fucking amazing food.
- Oh dude, I'll clown on their food,
but if someone was like, you
want a philly cheesesteak?
I'm gonna go, hell yeah I
want a philly cheesesteak.
- You want to go Chick-fil-A?
Yeah, yeah I do.
- Of course I do!
Like, Five Guys?
Of course I do--
- Oh my God.
Five Guys, bro.
- I fucking love Five Guys.
- We all love Five Guys.
- Destroying my body has
never felt so fucking good
until I discovered Five Guys, man.
- The best way to experience
Five Guys is at 3AM.
You're absolutely hammered from the booze,
and you're like, I need
something in my stomach.
Oh, Five Guys.
You go to Five Guys,
you get the greasiest fucking burger,
and while you're eating it,
it's like constant--
- It's the Cajun fries, man.
It's the Cajun fries.
- Cajun fries as well,
it's the Cajun fries,
but also the burger.
Just the combination of those two
is the best fucking thing in the world.
But I've never experienced life and death
at the same time while eating something,
you know what I mean?
It's like--
- How to experience.
- Every bite I take I'm like, oh,
God, I'm so glad I'm alive.
But then the moment it
goes down my esophagus,
I'm like, fuck,
I want to die right now.
Holy shit!
- I really want to do a
road trip around the US,
'cause it seems like there's
so many diverse cultures,
and cool shit they get up too.
- Every time I go to a new state,
I always try to go to a fast food chain
that's specific to that state.
Just because it's so different.
- I know you guys don't like In-N-Out,
but I fucking love In-N-Out.
- It's not that I don't like it in there,
I just think it's a bit overrated.
- I've never had In-N-Out.
- It's a bit over hyped, but.
- It's just, like it's good,
but it's not something
to froth over, you know?
- Dude, I fucking love it.
Whenever I go to LA,
and if Evan picks me up,
I'm like, Evan,
let's go In-N-Out right now.
I want to go In-N-Out right now.
- You know what's a really
good burger chain in Texas?
They have this burger
chain called Whataburger.
- Oh, I've heard about that.
- Wait, they have it
in California as well.
(inaudible)
- Yeah, but it was originally in Texas.
- Oh, okay.
- And Whataburger is fucking awesome.
Like the spicy sauce that
they have is so good.
- Yeah, like I feel like I'm dying,
but every single day I feel so happy
with the food I've eaten in America?
- [Joey] Yeah.
- But then I guess that would
wear off if I lived there everyday.
Right?
- I think so, yeah.
- Maybe.
I just feel so happy in the US,
and the food's amazing,
everyone's so kind.
The hotels are so spacious.
Dude, in London,
you pay like $200 for a closet.
- [Garnt] Yeah.
- If you're lucky.
If you're lucky, you might
have your own toilet.
- The hotel game in
England is just weak, man.
- It's the shittest thing on Earth.
- It's like the business
hotels here, right?
It's like, would you
like a bed and a hallway?
$200 dollars please.
- If you want a semi-competent
hotel in London,
you gotta pay like 300 pounds.
Or maybe 200 pounds if you
get lucky and find a good one,
but in America,
every single hotel I've been too,
except I've never been to a motel,
so I don't fuck with those,
'cause that's where people die in films.
(laughing)
I've had an amazing hotel experience.
- That's where fugitives hide out, right?
- Yeah, every single thing
that's bad happens near a motel,
so I've just,
my brain has been taught
don't go to a motel.
- Calling a motel a
hotel is the equivalent
of calling McDonald's a restaurant,
right?
(laughing)
It's like, (groans quickly)
no, it's not.
- I remember I was gonna
get a motel for my first AX,
and then the reviews were like,
someone was shot outside my room,
and there was cockroaches.
Two stars.
I'm like, two stars?
How many people had to
die for it to be one star?
(laughing)
Like, that was what?
- The only reason why it's a two
star is because I didn't die.
- The cockroaches didn't eat
me alive in my sleep, so.
- 'Cause I just feel like parts
of LA just feel like another world.
I don't know--
- It's a war zone.
- Yeah, it is.
Especially some of downtown LA.
- I remember the first morning
I woke up in a hotel in LA.
It was one of those alarm
clocks where the radio
starts to play the
moment the sun comes up?
And all I heard was, like,
its a lovely morning here in Los Angeles.
Three people got shot last night.
Have a good day.
(laughing)
- It's weird.
- Just like, cool.
- It's weird because when you listen
to the radio you're like,
whoa, shit.
GTA was super accurate?
(laughing)
Like whoa, this sounds exactly like GTA
when I listen to the radio in America.
- Yeah, legit.
After he said 'have a good day',
I was just waiting for the title
screen music to just start playing.
- I remember my first day in LA.
The first time I went to
LA was for Anime Expo.
I remember we were staying in
this Air BnB in downtown LA.
I remember the first day we went
to get a taxi to the convention center,
me and Sydney were just
waiting for our Uber outside
and then this homeless guy just
tries to start talking about this,
tries to start talking to us.
And I don't know what it
is about homeless guys,
not just in LA, but just in general.
They speak another language.
Like you can't understand
what they're saying--
- They speak in tongues.
- Is this what English sounds like
to non English speaking people?
(laughing)
That's the kind of
language that they speak.
And we're like,
(mumbling)
sorry, you know,
we're going off somewhere.
And so he walks off about
five meters past us,
whips his dick out,
and just starts peeing.
(laughing)
I'm like?
- Hell yeah.
- What is going on here?
- America.
- What is happening?
- I kind of had a similar experience
the first time I went to New York,
and (laughs quickly),
I remember I was just walking down,
I think it was Fourth Street or somewhere,
like one of the big Manhattan roads.
And I was just walking around being like,
oh, cool,
this is like every gangster movie,
like, this scenery.
This is fucking awesome.
And then this woman just
taps me on the soldier,
and I'm like, yes?
Can I help you?
And she's like,
did you know that Jesus
reincarnated in Korea in the 1940's?
I'm like, go on?
- I love it when those people talk to me.
- And I just let her talk,
and she was just going on.
And it's like I didn't even know,
because she sounded so sophisticated,
but the shit that was coming
out of her mouth was like,
oh, you've done a lot of drugs.
- Yeah.
- So I was just really enthralled.
I'm like, wow,
is this like a normal occurrence here?
I'd never get bored here if this happens.
- To be fair, I had
something like that in Japan.
- [Garnt] Yeah.
- Like four months ago?
I was walking, I had my headphones on,
I was going to the gym.
I clearly looked like I was
gonna go exercise, right?
I was dressed.
And then I heard someone
saying hello, hello!
And I'm like,
my brain clicked and I'm like
no one would say hello normally?
There's these three
seventy year old women.
- [Joey] Yeah?
- And they're like, are you English?
Are you English?
I'm like, yeah.
Yeah, yeah.
What's up, what can I do for you?
And they start showing me papers.
And it's like poorly
translated English that's,
like, some monk died or something,
and they were like, let's go pray,
let's go pray.
I'm like, I'm going gym?
(laughing)
- I gotta go get my gains!
- They're like, no,
no, no.
Come to the park near us,
come to the park, we'll go and pray.
We'll go and pray.
They were really nice about it,
but I was like, bro,
no, I said I'm going to the gym.
Let me go to the gym.
And they're like, no,
no, we must play now.
We must pray now.
- Are you serious?
- Yeah, yeah,
yeah, yeah.
And then they were like,
what do you do for work?
And I was like, oh yeah,
I do voice acting shit, I do YouTube,
and they were like, oh cool.
Let's go pray.
Let's go pray, let's go pray.
And then they just kept
asking me weird questions,
and every single time I'd say anything,
they were like, oh cool.
Let's go pray, let's go pray.
And I'm like, no--
- That's how cults start.
- Yeah, they're like four foot,
and I'm like get away from me.
You peasants.
- Knock them over.
- Peasants.
Back off, peasants.
I'm going to the gym, I
won't hear any of this.
And I have the thing,
it was something about
a war lord or something,
and how he died for
Mount Fuji and some shit?
And I was like what the fuck?
- We live nowhere near Mount Fuji?
- Yeah, yeah,
yeah, I was so confused.
I'm like, why do you want me to pray?
They were like,
everyone will be praying in this park.
They're like, everyone
will be praying there.
We will help you pray.
I'm like what the fuck?
- Who's everybody?
- I was so confused it was Japan, right?
And I just never experienced
anything like this in Japan.
People don't approach you.
- I experienced shit
like that in Shinjuku,
or Shibuya, late at night.
- It was right outside my house,
so I was really worried that
they knew where I lived.
I was literally right outside my door.
They're like, where do you live?
Show us where you live?
They kept asking me.
I'm like--
- Oh my God.
As the one foreigner in the area as well,
you're just instantly recognizable.
- Yeah, 'cause there's no
foreigners where I live.
So they were like, yeah,
where do you live, where do you live?
And I'm thinking my
house is right behind me,
and I'm like, over there.
(laughing)
Yeah, I'm over there.
Over there.
And then they kept asking me to pray!
I was like, leave me alone!
And when I kept walking away,
they kept following me to the fucking gym.
And then I went in the gym and
they finally left me alone,
'cause they obviously couldn't
get in 'cause you need a card.
- What if they just
whipped out the gym card--
- Yeah, let's pray!
- As you're doing it,
let's pray, let's pray--
- I'm like, you know what?
Fine.
I'll pray if you spot me, come on.
(laughing)
Jesus Christ.
I am genuinely creeped out,
'cause I was worried that
when I went in the gym
that they were gonna stay
there until I was done.
I was like, why me?
Is it 'cause I'm White?
Like, leave me alone.
- It's because you're
finally the minority.
- Yeah.
(laughing)
What did I do?
Leave me alone, bro.
That was way creepier than any LA.
Actually, no.
That's pretty creepy.
- The LA stuff's pretty creepy.
- It's just 'cause I'm so,
as someone from England,
and basically, you know,
all of Europe and also Asia,
it's pretty safe to walk around here.
- Yeah.
- Anywhere you try,
if you need to go home
or walk to a new bar,
you just walk there.
In America, if you go,
you can be at the nicest bar,
and one block away you
can get shot or something
if you just take a wrong turn.
- Bro, I was so scared walking
in San Francisco at 1AM.
I was like, oh my God,
I'm gonna die.
I'm texting my friends being like,
you can have my stuff, bro.
Take my YouTube channel, it's all over.
- Here's the password.
- It's 1AM in San Fran, bro.
I'm dead.
- Yeah.
Yeah, and I remember,
I think it was AX two years ago,
where we had a hotel suite
and we also had an Air BnB,
and it was only like five minutes
walk away from each other.
- Your Air BnB was so scary!
- It was, wasn't it!
It was a fucking great Air BnB.
It was like the chillest Air BnB.
We had a fucking pool
table and everything,
but it just seemed in the dodgiest area.
- That was where the homeless
guy thing happened with me.
- 'Cause I remember, like,
we were gonna go to your
Air BnB for a house party,
and you gave me the coordinates.
I'm like, oh,
it's just down the road.
So we just start walking,
and then it's like,
it's telling me to turn
into this alleyway?
And then I was like, nah,
Garnt's just fucking with me.
- It just gets darker,
and darker, and darker.
'Cause I remember I invited John,
Super Eyepatch Wolf, to the party as well,
and I gave him the general area, right?
And he was having trouble finding it.
And I remember trying
to run out to get him,
to go come to the party,
and he was down the road,
so all he saw was some guy coming out
in this dark alleyway shouting John,
John, John!
And he just fucking turns round,
and just walks around the corner,
'cause I can't imagine
what he was thinking.
(laughing)
- I'm out of here, I'm out of here.
- No, no,
no.
- Na, na.
Not today, not today.
- Oh my God.
- That was where we had the homeless guy.
I pushed over a homeless guy.
I know that sounds terrible--
- [Joey] Oh yeah, you
fought a homeless guy!
- That sounds terrible.
I didn't fight him, I
just pushed him over.
This sounds terrible, by the way.
Connor's just going around
pushing over homeless people.
So it was like 3AM,
and I was walking to the
hotel from the Air BnB,
and it was already sketchy
as fuck, this area--
- [Joey] Oh yeah, yeah.
- And there was a woman crying
on the floor in a corner,
and this guy with no
shirt on, just shorts,
like, tattoos all over.
He was like five foot, no,
like four foot ten.
Like, he was small as fuck,
and he was malnourished, he had no teeth.
And he was just screaming at this girl,
like, threatening her in the corner.
And I was like, well shit,
I have to say something.
So in my awkward British self,
I was like, hey,
um, could you stop doing that?
I think she doesn't
like it is what I said.
And he was like, who the
fuck you think you are man?
Who the fuck you think,
you know, talking to me.
I think he was Hispanic or something?
And he was squaring up to me,
and I was like, man,
come on.
Just leave her alone, man.
She's clearly not wanting to talk to you,
When I say talk, he was
just screeching at her.
I don't know what happened.
She was on the floor crying.
And so when he comes
over to me, she runs off.
- [Joey] Yeah.
- Great, she's gone.
She's safe.
And then, from what I
can remember at the time,
'cause I was little drunk, a bit,
he is this close to me,
shouting in my face.
And I'm like, okay.
What's gonna happen here?
I'm just gonna walk away now.
And so he grabs something from his pocket.
I don't know what he's gonna do,
so I just push him over and run away.
- [Garnt] Yeah.
- [Joey] Jesus Christ.
- 'Cause I'm like, fuck.
I don't know what this guy's gonna do.
I'm scared as fuck, I don't
know what's happening--
- I would not have the balls to be like,
hey, can you stop please?
- Well, 'cause she was like,
it was like no one else around,
and this girl was crying her eyes out,
and I was like, well,
hey, hey man.
Could you stop it?
Like basically.
And then he got really angry at me,
and I was like, fuck,
fuck, okay.
And then I thought he was
gonna hit me or something,
so I was like, fuck it,
and pushed him.
- If I saw someone reaching
for their pocket like that,
I'd do exactly--
- I feel bad,
'cause didn't swing at me or anything?
But he was going for his pocket,
and I'm like, fuck.
(laughing)
I literally fucking sprinted away.
I ran around the corner,
I was like, (panting),
in my hotel like (panting).
- Yeah, and to put this in perspective,
like, again,
our Air BnB was like five minutes
away from the Intercontinental,
or some very famous hotel chain.
So you just don't get
something like this here,
or like, in Europe?
- No--
- So we are just not used to this,
that you have to literally drive
five minutes down the road.
Not even five minutes down the road,
because it was a five minute walk,
just because this is the shit
that can happen in between.
- Yeah, I learned my lesson at that time.
Just probably not walking around.
- [Joey] Yeah.
- Don't intervene if you're not
willing to push someone over I guess?
I don't really know.
I didn't feel great
about pushing him over,
because he was way smaller than me.
But like, I don't know.
- But you never know if he was gonna,
like, just pull out a gun.
- Yeah, exactly--
- The guy clearly was on something.
He was out of it, like spouting nonsense.
Like, he wasn't talking English.
I mean, he was trying to,
but, you know.
I mean, I don't know what he was on,
but it was scary.
- Terrifying.
- Yeah.
Anyway, anything you want to talk about,
or is that where we should end today?
- I'm not trying to
demonize homeless people.
I think most of them are
super chill and really nice,
I just had those one or two interactions
that scared the fuck out of me.
(laughing)
That's all,
just want to make that out
there before people shit on me.
- In case there are any
homeless people watching.
(an)
He's cool with you guys, it's alright.
- Also any Americans as well.
- Oh yeah, yeah.
We say all this shit about
Americans and America,
but we're okay with you guys, alright?
- This is just the culture
shock that we get--
- Exactly, exactly.
- Whenever we visit
there for the first time,
or anything like that.
- You guys are cool, right,
for a lot of the time.
- I love you, America.
You're great.
- You're very entertaining.
(laughing)
In more ways than one.
- We just have a lot of great stories
to tell whenever we go there.
- Something happens, man.
Something always happens.
- Something always happens.
- When we get to the convention episodes,
that's when the real--
- Oh.
- That's when the real
stories start coming out--
- We're saving all the
good stories for that.
Yeah, definitely.
In the meantime though,
thank you to all the
Patreon's for this episode,
as you can see.
If you would like your name
on the screen right now,
then feel free to go over to our
Patreon if you wanna support us.
- [Garnt] Look at all
these beautiful names.
- All these beautiful.
- [Garnt] Look at this
guy, this guy is beautiful.
- I like that guy.
- Look at all these people
who don't shit in pumpkins.
Really proud of all you guys.
Really, really proud.
- If you don't shit in mailboxes,
then consider signing up to our Patreon.
- Someone's like, dammit,
I've shit.
- Guess I have to uninstall now.
- If anyone else has a
poop story in university--
- No, no,
no, no,
- If you have a poop story in university,
feel free to leave it on the subreddit.
We'd love to hear it.
And also follow us on Twitter as well.
- [Connor] Yeah, go follow Twitter's,
Twitch's, YouTube--
- Yeah, all that good shit.
It's all in the description.
- We've been the neanderthals?
And this is Trash Taste.
- We are the men who
don't poop in mailboxes.
- I don't do that now.
- Anymore.
(laughing)
- I'm a changed man.
Alright, bye bye.
- [Joey] See you.
(upbeat music)